the only thing they can be short of
about the future is it will be
absolutely fantastic I'm talking with
dr. Stephen Wolfram who's I've known
fortunately for me for many years I've
been fortunate to receive signed copies
of his books this is one of my favorite
books good which is which is quite an
accomplishment because you know as a CEO
you know that there's very few CEOs who
are very technically or mathematically
minded and getting insight into
physicists and mathematicians and
thinkers philosophers from the mind of a
CEO and a mathematician scientist is
quite refreshing so I actually work hard
to learn the craft of leadership not
just the craft of cosmology so I thank
you for this book I recommend it very
highly idea makers will spend a little
time talking about that first I want to
I will happen you know your general bio
I just want to add to my listeners I've
got a lot of young listeners out there I
have old listeners everything in between
we talked about everything in this
podcast from physics of sports and the
Olympics and Krav Maga to business
leaders to cosmologists and everything
but in between but this is the first
time I've had on somebody who never got
a PhD but I don't think I've ever had
someone who didn't get a asher's degree
and the person who didn't get a PhD was
Freeman Dyson who I know you know knew
the late Freeman Dyson and the man I'm
talking to now is dr. Stephen Wolfram
but he never got a bachelor's degree so
I think I was saying to one of my
friends if you put the two of you guys
together you get a really good physicist
Stephen welcome thanks so I wanted to
think ask you a question just to start
off that you've made many contributions
to be to the mechanics not just the
theory and practice of mathematical
reasoning but you've actually introduced
technology that has in my estimation I
mean tell me if you agree with this
probably perform more calculations than
every single abacus and every single
why droll ever invented you would you
agree with that estimate yes I'm sure
that's stupid we haven't we have a huge
advantage you know dealing with
computers that run a billion
instructions per second yeah why would
the abacus is running at most you know
an instruction maybe two instructions a
second so and it's like a billion
advantage with me a Miller hurts my
processor runs about a Miller Hertz and
I wanted to kind of start off there
because you're today I contacted you
because I like so many of my colleagues
are so excited about this new physics
project that will firm is involved with
and that you pioneer it I want to
understand how it came to be how you
were inspired by young people in your
life because we have a mission here to
inspire the imagination of young and old
and and this particular was kicked off
by young people and how it's made its
way into the world but that connection
to technology sort of intrigued me when
I when I had that realization that you
had completed more calculations by
orders of magnitude than any other
device invented before the computers LSA
it made me think like what what would
have happened you know had you been born
a century earlier for example were born
into the technology that we have and
there are certain bounds and what
technology you can create and you you
proposed this new physics project but
would that have been possible you know
thirty years earlier or 50 you right
what do you feel about that yeah I think
the answer is basically no for two
reasons first reason is a really
practical one which is you know part of
how we know what's true is by doing
experiments we can now do computational
experiments that's a fairly new thing if
we've been a lot lot smarter than we are
we might have been able to figure out
what was true without doing the
experiments but I don't think that's
feasible so the first thing is the
practicality of being able to do
computer experiments the second thing is
the way of thinking about things that
computation has brought to us is
something that comes about because we're
just used to computation all around us
and that's that's a sort of paradigmatic
advance that I just think is not
achievable without sort of a lot of
exposure to computation in the wild so
to speak I mean I you know I've been
very interested in the sort of history
of ideas and
some of the things I've discovered are
things where I say gosh you know one day
we're gonna unearth some Babylonian
tablet that's gonna have one of these
things that I've that I've identified
and you know they were close they did
some things that weren't you know I've
studied a lot how simple programs work
how when you have very simple rules you
just keep applying these rules over and
over again you end up not getting simple
things out but you end up getting very
complicated things out and you know I've
I've often wondered could the
Babylonians have discovered that mmm and
so I think mechanically the answer is
yes but would they have known what it
meant I think the answer is no and I
think that's the and I know in my own
life the understanding what it means is
the much slower thing than the mechanics
of being able to do it but you know a
lot of the stuff I've been doing now how
would the physics project couldn't have
even done the experiments without having
computers and we're talking you know
routinely I'm talking I'm I'm you know
routine simple experiment that I might
do might involve a hundred billion or
trillion operations you know a hundred
computers doesn't take them very long to
run that for me it's just like oh I
could just do that on a whim so to speak
but a trillion operations you know
there's there's what there's twelve
million stones in the Great Pyramid for
example that's and other stones are
bigger the lift then my little
operations but it still gives you a
sense of scale a trillion operations is
a lot of a lot of effort yeah and to do
this and then you know naturally then
you know my mind went to well what would
happen if if Steven or you know your
protegees your many protegees came up
with it not now but thirty years hence
and it it really kind of reminded me a
little bit of what Steve Jobs was
reputed to have said once he was he was
asked to give to some philanthropy to
some charity and he said no and his
reason was you know he could take money
now and invest that money much better
than the charity could and then at the
end of his life which unfortunately that
very long he would he would then donate
a much larger sum so he sort of
proclaimed this you know the virtue of
slaw if I recall correctly and I wonder
you know with the advent of quantum
computers and
I haven't read apologies if you have
discussed this I'm trying to keep
up-to-date with all your output but what
the bearing on quantum computing could
have on it I know there are packages and
we'll talk about Wolfram language and so
forth but but what about had this not
come for 30 years you think in the net
aggregate that visits would be delayed
or stalled by some amount yeah so I mean
well by the way about quantum computers
one of the implications of this theory
of physics is it gives us kind of a new
cleaner way to think about quantum
computing both what it can do and what
it cannot do so I think that that story
is about to have some slightly different
turns in it I wouldn't hold out the hope
for them and you know that the fact is
computers get faster only rather slowly
these days but in terms of you know when
the things happen when is the right time
and so on you know I've been lucky in
that I've lived in a period of history
where something which is really
interesting to me and which I maybe even
quite suitable to doing which is
studying computation has just been sort
of coming online and I I do think you
know I always think about people in
general you know you I always have this
theory that for every person there's
sort of the the ideal niche and the
question is does that niche exist at
this time in history and you know what I
see when I you know I've been involved
in introducing a number of sorts of
ideas that end up getting lots of people
involved in working on them and so on
and what I see is that that when one of
these new ideas comes out and we're
seeing that now in the physics project
there'll be a group of people for whom
these ideas will really resonate with
the things that they're interested in
those people may be young they may be
not so young and it's like well we
lucked out because you know at some
point during their career something came
up that really resonated with what
they're interested in and then they can
go off and really make you know make a
success of it and I think you know in in
you know if you live at the current time
and the thing that you really want to do
is you know explore the the source of
unexplored rivers while you're out of
luck cuz all the sources of all the
rivers on the earth are knowing you know
if you want to you know they're
different things that become possible at
different times in history and as I said
I
lucky that this this thing of
computation kind of during my lifetime
has gone from something very kind of
embryonic to something that is at least
better developed I think we're far from
all the way through but you know so I've
been I've been kind of fortunate you
know I was I was observing as I a lot of
what I do in sort of the raw material of
the work I do is computer experiments
you know what do all these simple
programs actually do and I think I even
I even wrote in some recent post of mine
you know if I had lived in a different
century I think I would have been a
zoologist
because Here I am looking at all these
weird things that these programs do and
trying to classify them trying to
understand what they are now I'm truth
is I'm I'm a really squeamish person so
I don't think I would have made it a
zoologist but that would have been at
least my my potential interest so to
speak but ya know it'sit's some I mean
this question about when are ideas ready
to happen in the world it's really
interesting questions so you know one of
the things that I think is sort of the
most interesting probably the most
interesting single discovery I've made
is by made in the 80s is this phenomenon
that even really simple programs so you
know when you think of a program you
usually think of something you write
explicitly for some purpose but you can
also imagine sort of the most scientific
question just like pick a program at
random tiny little program a program
it's just a line long just a few rules
for what it does and say what does it do
and you might have thought as I did oh
it'll only do really simple things but
it turns out that isn't true turns out
that you know even this really simple
program can do really complicated things
and that for me was sort of a a big sort
of intuition breaking moment when I
realized that now it's also worth saying
when I actually discovered that it's a
little bit embarrassing but you know I
first did those experiments probably
1981 yeah I did the experiments where I
had you know these printouts even
publish them in a paper with these
printouts with you know all these things
where I got very complicated behavior
with very simple initial conditions and
etc etc but I mostly focused on another
aspect of what was going on mostly
focused on on something about how order
was created not how the synonymous was
created took me three more years to
realize that this thing that was
right in front of me was something
really important and then I kind of
realized you know well haven't people
seen this phenomenon before and I
realized well actually you know when you
look at like the digits of pi they're
very simple to specify yet once you
generate those digits they seem for
practical purposes you know people
remember 3.14159 etc etc it's kind of a
game to see how many you can remember
it's hard to remember them because
they're kind of random yeah I use the
middle four digits as my pin number of
pies oh you shouldn't tell people the
middle yes sir you can go any distance
to get to the middle yeah yeah we had a
thing actually on the pi day of the
century we had thing where you could
type in your birthday and it would show
you where in Peyer but wow you didn't
know good stuff no Peter security uh
that's right no that's possible yeah but
but but no you know I think what
happened there is something like in
digits of pi there is this randomness
that once saw there but nobody really
cared it was just like that's random we
can't say anything about it same with
primes people were you know the
distribution of primes which numbers you
know 2 3 5 7 11 etcetera etcetera
etcetera that the which numbers are
prime plot them out it's kind of random
in some ways there's a certain density
of them but otherwise it's sort of
random fluctuations so there's endless
mathematics done on the distribution of
primes looking for the regularities in
the distribution of projects around
pairs yeah right and all sorts of you
know what's the density of primes that's
the prime number theorem
you know the Riemann hypothesis is all
about certain aspects of the density of
primes and so on a lot of famous
well-known mathematics about the
regularities in the distribution of
primes but actually one of the most
striking things about the distribution
of primes is the apparent randomness of
the distribution of primes and you know
before the kinds of things that I've
done nobody cared about that it was it
was so you know what you find and I find
it really interesting actually that the
there these phenomena that the
phenomenon is there but nobody cares you
have to have a sort of paradigm wrapped
around it to make people want to care
you know I think that's the for me
personally that's been the main limiting
factor in progress is getting the point
where I have enough sort of ambient
understanding that I can see what the
questions should be and see why one can
care about the phenomena one seeing yeah
and I wonder you know just going back in
your history and people you know can
certainly read about it in all sorts of
places and we'll put links to your
biography I don't like spending too much
time with people that you know asking
questions that almost anybody can
research even on WolframAlpha itself I
want to just ask you though something
that is a commonality and all your work
since I started following you in the 90s
my father you know was one of the main
reasons that we could talk to each other
is because I could actually program in
Mathematica in the 90s and and he was
interested in proving some some new
theorems and quantum mechanics and
relativity and things in this later
years but I wondered you know as we
would go through it the sort of thing
I'd always appealed to me even before
you came out with sort of this notion
overarching languages that you're really
kind of a linguist in the sense that
that these these different natural
language or algorithmic basis for
language we're certainly going to get
into more of that in a moment
but would you say that's accurate that
that's sort of you have this if you were
to reproduce the or reduce the
irreducible complexity of you you were
just talking about the irreducible
complexity of at its core would you find
you know the prime numbers of Stephen
Wolfram have to do with fascination with
the language encoding and algorithms I
don't know I you know because I'm one of
these people who's been involved in well
you know finding managing lots of
talented people and I kind of try to
understand sort of how how to get the
best things out of people and oneself
one of the things that sort of an
exercise for me is what am I actually
good at doing and I've you know I've
done a lot of different projects that in
science and technology and so on and I
sort of realized at some point there are
actually all the same project at some
level and the way the project works is I
mean the subject matter is different its
physics its computational knowledge it's
you know computational language design
its things about the computational
universe
and so on but but basically that the the
pattern of my projects and they often
very long projects tends to be there's
some big complicated thing out there I
then try and sort of drill down and
figure out what are the sort of
underlying essential primitives and then
having got those underlying essential
primitives then try and build the whole
thing up again as a sort of piece of
engineering
to actually make something that is sort
of a big story a piece of technology
that's useful or whatever else now in
doing that one of the things that
certainly comes up is when you break
things down to those sort of underlying
primitives what are they and how do you
describe them and you know I've spent
some significant part of my life as a
computational language designer and what
that means it's so the opposite of what
a linguist does a linguist says we've
got these languages that all these
humans speak what are they made of you
know what how do they come to be and
that's much more of a I mean that tends
to be much more of a kind of sort of a
hey what did we get thrown by the
certainly this apparent historical
accident of linguistic evolution
whereas what I've been interested in
doing although it's not quite as far
away as it might at first see is to take
what are the set of things that are sort
of possible with computation and then
figure out how do we describe those with
a language so what does it mean to
describe it with the language what one's
really doing there is there's this whole
ocean of sort of what's possible to do
computationally and then there's the
parts of that that we humans actually
care about you know you can run an
infinite set of possible programs many
of them will do things that if you were
to make a living studying them you know
make your you would say oh that's really
interesting but without a context for
them it's like why do we care there's a
certain set of things that we humans
have decided we care about and the role
of a computational language designer is
to kind of make this bridge between the
things that we humans think we care
about at a particular time in history
and the things that can be done
computationally so it's like for example
the thing we might be doing you know
right now a podcast right there wasn't a
word for that thing 20 years ago
and um and yet and so we see the sort of
circular process there's this sort of
thing that eventually happens in the
world eventually it makes sense to kind
of describe it in some sort of symbolic
way of oh that's a podcast and what's
funny about the way that human you know
sort of civilization evolves is once you
have this way to describe it it's much
easier to have more of it so to speak
because people know you know you asked
me do you want to be on this podcast I
know what you're talking about whereas
you know otherwise it would be this long
complicated description that so you know
in some sense this process I mean I I
see my you know a large part of what I
do is sort of this interface between
what we humans kind of understand or
interested in and what's possible the
computational level hmm actually that
that's a that's one of the things that's
kind of interesting to me about this
physics project is that to me in some
ways this is the ultimate language
design problem because you know what do
we have going on we have we say what is
the universe gonna do well we don't
really need to have a theory for that we
just watch the universe see what it does
on the other hand we have you know we
have this kind of the goal of a theory
of physics is to have something where we
humans can sort of tell a story about
how the universe works the universe does
whatever it does but can we reduce that
to something which we can tell a story
about so to speak and is computable
that's right yeah so speaking of you
know languages and creation I want to
first take a little step back before we
get into the to the nuts and bolts of
the physics project back to some
exposure that all of our listeners since
we are named after the arthur c clarke
legacy the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination and the podcast name
itself is into the impossible which Kant
derives from sir arthur c clarke second
law which is the only way to find out
what's possible is to venture out a
little bit into the impossible and
that's where we get that name of course
the first law of arthur c clarke also
applies to you in many cases because
it's it's essentially a statement about
technology that any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic
leigh
I do want to get to you know just as a
teaser but for folks that are listening
to hopefully enjoy the entirety in the
podcast cuz I do want to you know maybe
tickle your brain a little bit and talk
about some of the philosophical or maybe
perhaps even theological implications of
creating magical technology s or arthur
c clarke would say and i want to i want
to pick your brain about that but first
i want to take a step back to perhaps
you know i think you're known in the
popular culture you know for for many
things but one thing i think you're
known for you know particularly is well
besides the fact that you're in you know
roughly half the pockets of people in
the world on in terms of siri and the by
setting off some some smart systems
around the world by mentioning this but
WolframAlpha powers so many of the
different different search queries that
siri will actually execute and i do want
to point out i'm in the show notes i'm
going to have some links to WolframAlpha
and have some exercises for for kids and
adults even to play around with to get a
feeling for how the symbolic computation
may work it's such a powerful app you
know compared to what you might just be
using on your you know i now have gotten
to just you know yelling out into the
ether to my smart assistant to do some
calculation but but it's so much more
fun and necessarily you know associative
when you do it on something like
WolframAlpha so we'll talk about that
that's one area of the zeitgeist that
you're deeply enmeshed when the other
one is is your role in your son
Christopher's role in the movie arrival
where you were tasked with something
that is just delightfully mercurial and
knowing you that's your signature
trademark of creating a language two of
you have created sort of the language
that was used in the film I do want to
point out that the story of your life
which is written by Ted Chang no we had
the world premieres of it with him back
in 2016 here as part of the arthur c
clarke center i'll put a link to that
also in the show notes so people can
watch that video at ted and members of
the arthur c clarke center but i want to
talk about this this arrivals story
because i think in a lot of ways I often
think about you know how would you
communicate what are some universal you
know communications that that you can
have and I
I gave a talk once at the SETI Institute
in which I invoked your former friend
and mentor richard fineman where he
talked about if you ever met an alien
and he or she or it orgy or whatever
sticks out its left hand to shake your
hand don't don't do it because it's
probably made of antimatter and
therefore you'd be annihilated he said
so this is in his fine man lectures on
physics which you might have actually
taken as a graduate student perhaps or
certainly known about them but I I read
them when I was a kid yeah so wondering
whether or not you know how you would
communicate symbolically and the talk I
gave at the SETI Institute I pointed out
you know perhaps you could use the
Cosmic Microwave Background its patterns
as a way to distinguish in fineman's
question how do you tell them that the
heart of a human being is located on its
left side well the first thing they're
going to say is what's your left what
does that even mean and I wonder you
know in the construction of that talk
that I gave you know how would you do it
and and for you to come up with this
language can you walk us through that
that exercise and what it was like and
why of all things to spend your time on
you did get so deeply invested in that
wonderful movie well the the the movie
thing was that was a lucky thing because
it was it was one of these I think
movies are a very high noise activity
that is there's a you know there's a lot
of things people talk about doing and a
small fraction of them actually get done
this was a case where we were we were
sort of fortunate enough to get involved
with that movie right when it was about
to start filming and when it was sort of
when it was it was for certain that
something was going to happen and it's
also it was very much a tribute to the
director that you know that the movie
came out as well as it did because I you
know when I first read the screenplay it
was like oh my gosh how are you gonna
make you it's such a it's very
interesting but very complicated story
you know what are you can do with it um
but you know this whole problem of how
do you communicate beyond the sort of
our existing culture i've thought quite
a bit about this I actually wrote a
piece about that I I got involved friend
of mine has a thing called the arch
mission which his goal is to put
artifacts
from our civilization out into the solar
system as sort of beacons of this is
what those humans achieved if the
extraterrestrials come through long
after were extinct okay and so what one
of the dramas last year actually there
was a some stuff that these guys had put
on the Israeli moon lander yes that was
some so you know I was kind of watching
you know what's gonna happen with the
Israeli moon land it's really a cool
mission and the end it's oh gosh the
thing crashed into the moon at
twenty-five hundred miles an hour yeah
still sell a better driver than some of
my Israeli friends
just kidding out there I'm not nothing
well let me tell you something about
that that we figured out so you know I
was curious did the payload survive yeah
right yeah and so initially I thought no
way 2500 miles an hour is a lot of
chance the the that turns out I I got in
touch with a person who sort of world
expert in cratering and one of the
things that was interesting was that
spacecraft impacted the moon at I forget
what it was maybe a 15 degree angle
maybe less than that in that very
grazing angle what it didn't do all that
correctly that was that was kind of what
went wrong and so you know it was cold
well actually at that angle the thing
doesn't just go splat it bounces and in
fact we then got some some footage from
the Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter and you
can see there's this little ray that
shoots out and we calculated where the
thing had been and so on which was a
little bit tricky because it was a it
wasn't didn't there's no GPS for the
moon but you have to take outfit off so
you have to match them up with craters
and things like this well anyway there's
a there's a ray going out from the
impact site right at the correct angle
so I'm pretty sure the payload actually
survived so so on the moon there is
something which I don't think is gonna
work for the extraterrestrials it was an
attempt and so the question is what can
you put there and what is the sign that
you know tells them something
interesting about our civilization I
think in the end this is a
philosophically doomed project okay so
in other words we can start thinking
about what do you do so so for instance
one
let's imagine we're really advanced
civilization and we can move stars
around okay and we want to put a sign in
the galaxy saying we're really smart
over here why tonight lived here right
Einstein lived here right yeah yeah all
right you know what what configuration
of stars do we put in that yeah well you
might say well let's put them in a
perfect geometrical figure okay bad idea
because there's lots of physics that
leads to perfect geometrical figures you
know so that's not an immediately you
might say you know like pulsars for
example you know when they were first
detected in 1967 I guess um you know
people were like for the first couple of
weeks they were like there's a radio
signal it's going bbbbbb beep
periodically
you know that must be an
extraterrestrial beacon yeah well
actually no it's just a rotating neutron
star um and you know the periodic thing
just isn't something sort of
sophisticated enough that you can know
oh that couldn't just be a simple
physical process right or a maser we
have major examples in space and
absolutely when you're on earth so it's
not a sign of intelligence yeah right so
I mean that the challenge is what do you
find and actually one of the nice
stories from the past is back around go
120 years ago or something when radio
was new okay so there was Marconi there
was Tesla these were people who were
working on radio and Marconi observed
you had this yacht he went across Susie
it was a good business person and had
had got a yacht but he went across the
Atlantic in and in the middle of the
Atlantic with his radio mast he heard
all these weird
whooshing sounds and so on earth is this
Tesla was a little bit more forward in
his theory making and he said look it's
got to be the Martian signaling us I
mean what else could possibly have radio
you know radio must be a sign of the
Martians so to speak all right and the
you know what is it in fact its features
of the ionosphere you know it's kind of
whistlers right yeah and um but then the
thing that's really the confusing thing
for me is listen to whale song
recordings they sound awfully like that
yeah in other words you got this thing
that's produced by the ionosphere
just a just a physical process you got
this thing that's made by whales but at
some level is a physical process
happening in the brains of the whales
but we think it has more meaning than
that probably although we don't really
know for sure yeah and so you quickly
realize this is a difficult problem and
you know we look at archaeological
artifacts we say you know what what was
Stonehenge for well we're not quite sure
you know what were these things you know
you find some Flint that was you know
seem to be chipped off was that done on
purpose to make an arrowhead the way
that we get to know whether these things
were sort of on purpose is when there's
a kind of thread of intentionality
between those things and us so for
example if we recognize oh that was a
thing you know I remember I was visiting
some archaeological site in in Peru
recently and very interesting sites one
of the earliest kind of settlement type
things in the Americas um so going
around and you know that's the stone
thing and they're a bunch of different
structures and um you know the person is
very it's a very isolated site so the
work what a lot of tourists there but
you know the person we had showing us
around was like said what's that for
so well that was for ceremonial purposes
and so you know you quickly learn it's
ceremonial purpura sharor that said yet
marriage we have no idea what this was
for well you know I'm thinking about
things that exist in today's world you
know that that shopping mall was for
ceremonial purposes so how do you tell
you know how do you how do you connect
you know when we have a certain cultural
experience we can connect that sort of
thread of purpose or that sort of spark
of this was done on purpose to something
that we see in the world and that when
we don't have that connection it's
really hard yeah and I mean in the case
of sort of the extraterrestrial case
it's you know I I think it is not
something you can ever count on really
being there and I think the way to think
about that is well my statement in Rhys
years has been you know when you think
about intelligence I don't think there's
sort of a bright line between the
intelligent and the merely computational
so to speak so you know people say
things like you know the weather has a
mind of its own the weather seems to do
things that are very hard for us to
predict it seems to have you know it
seems to sort of decide what to do
itself ok does the weather have a
purpose we don't think so but you know
I'm not sure maybe the purpose of the
weather is to transport you know hot air
to this part of the of the world and
transport cold air to the other and so
on um but so but you know it's really
hard for us to say you know and then to
say well it it the the sort of the
process of the weather doing its thing
is an exercise of computation that at
least based on basically a bunch of
science I've done is sort of no more no
more or less sophisticated than the
kinds of computations that like go on in
our brains yeah so it's kind of like
that we're we're saying there's a
computation here it's equivalent to the
computation there we say we care more
about the computation going on in our
brain because it seems to have meaning
to us the weather doesn't seem to have
meaning to us because it doesn't have
this connection running away that sort
of other brains do so I mean I think
that's the and so when you sort of
extend that to the rest of the universe
it's like does that pulsar magnetosphere
have a meaning or not very hard to say
right now no the thing I have tended to
think is that our first example of alien
intelligence that we sort of understand
is rapidly emerging in the form of
artificial intelligence I mean when we
see an AI we we know we made it it's a
program that we created but we say
what's it doing is it doing something
you know and and how do we think about
what it's doing how do we think about
what it's thinking about so to speak
right we open it up it looks like it
might be an EEG recording from a human
brain it looks complicated and random
and we you know well we know how we
constructed it we don't know sort of we
don't have a narrative that explains why
it does what it does anymore so then we
have an arrow
that explains why our brains do what
they do in detail and so I think it's
it's some this mutt my my basic
statement is people will stop worrying
about extraterrestrial intelligence once
they really understand AI don't realize
that things out there are intelligent in
the sense that they are so have this
computational capability that's just
like us right this question of whether
they have an alignment and meaning is a
is a deeply detailed historical question
that isn't an abstract question it's not
like you say you know the the this you
know is the pulsar magnetosphere
intelligent is it a civilization that it
grow up over large numbers of time who's
to say it's really the looking at Tim I
mean one of the things that's come out
of this physics project of mine recently
is I always said him when I was working
on that arrival move is one of the
things I sort of said was that will at
least any extraterrestrial intelligence
has the same physics that we do it lives
in the same universe dimensions right
and it's light come but but I don't
think it's true because what I realized
is that that and this is service a
sophisticated point from it comes from
this physics project that there are
these kinds of ways of understanding the
physical world which are in some sense
it's the same physical world but there
are deeply incoherent ways of
understanding it so for example you know
our understanding of the world is sort
of based on our senses you know we have
we see we detect light we do this we do
that and you know there are little
details like for example for us we look
out in the world most of the things that
because the speed of light is really
fast compared to the speed of our brains
right what we see out there in the world
happened you know immediately so to
speak it's not the case that but if we
if we proceed primarily through sound we
would have a very different description
of relativity and in fact my father my
late father wrote a paper about
relativity for bats I mean bats are
getting a lot of a lot of a lot of bad
press these days but but yeah
communicating with echolocation and so
they might have a different series of
Lorentz invariant type objects I don't
have to look that up yes from the it's
from the 70s but but yes you're right
it's sort of a reflection of our own
prejudices how we write down the laws of
physics so is that what you're getting
at that that aliens might have different
perceptions like the ones in it and an
arrival and therefore their laws of
physics might be revealing something
totally different and we are completely
blind too so yeah yeah I mean I think
it's one of the that's the most extreme
case I mean the first issue is even when
it's the same physical processes even
when we're understanding noticing the
same things we're seeing light we're
seeing other things even then connecting
meaning seems essentially impossible but
even going beyond that when we're asking
is it really the same physics are we are
we
sensing I I think the more extreme case
than bats that I've been curious about
is dogs because they you know olfaction
these mouths their smell something for
them and the speed of olfaction
is really slow yeah I mean it's the
speed of diffusion of molecules in air
and that's some you know so for that the
dog is walking is definitive you know
for a bat a bat is flying splat slower
than the speed of sound but a dog is
walking faster than the speed of
olfaction and so it's view of things
like relativity will be even more
bizarrely different now that there are
you know that it isn't the case the sort
of constancy of the speed of light that
happens in physical universe it doesn't
quite work the same way for our faction
or for sound because there's actually an
ether so to speak and I think I think I
know what you should call this I think
you should call to the theory of smella
tivity I couldn't I'm sorry Steven go on
go on yeah no no I mean I think that you
know the thing that has been I think one
of the surprises from this physics work
that I've done recently is this
realization that again this is a
slightly complicated thing and I'm sort
of skipping way ahead yeah one of let's
not skip it well we get to it yes I do
want to get to that yeah and I think you
know the exercise in kind of
constructing these virtual worlds and
that's something that we do here at the
Arthur
Center we don't construct them but we
envision them you know what will San
Diego look like in 50 years how will we
be communicating what will be the
fundamental irreducible aspect that
leads to future life being better than
present life and I think obviously for
us that cleaves towards this notion of
creativity and imagination and I wonder
to what extent you were influenced by
science fiction I know you've had an
influence on science fiction our
namesake arthur c clarke of course was
influential in both science nonfiction
and science fiction and sort of this
this perception that we come to is that
from talking with colleagues such as dr.
david brin and even michael shermer I
was on the podcast recently that science
fiction represents sort of a way to to
to pregame to sort of think about the
future as a Gedanken experiment and play
around with it and maybe not with the
hopes of you know really coming up with
well what's the first you know message
that we send to thee to the aliens that
when they arrive but but more how we
understand ourselves better and and I
wonder if if say working on arrival did
it have any beneficial I mean just as a
short make it any way into the physics
project okay that's an amusing question
I mean so just to mention I I actually
wrote recently a long post about 2001 a
Space Odyssey it was the 50th
anniversary I'll have to post a link to
it yeah right I realized it was it was
the first movie that I had ever seen in
a movie theater and it turns out it was
because I saw I saw in England when it
was kind of just first out they were
handing out these programs in the movie
theater and cuz I'm a kind of archivist
packrat
I had the program that I'd been given
when I was like 8 years old or something
that this this movie so that was cut it
was kind of fun but you know it was
interesting to go back and look at 2001
you know I really liked that movie it
was a it was a very kind of bright view
of the future and I think it was you
know in many ways quite influential to
me in terms of sort of this this concept
of what what the future might be like I
was kind of amused going back to look at
it and seeing the things that were got
right the things that were got wrong the
things where you know
the whole computer that's in 2001 the
kind of intelligent computer you know in
many ways the things I've built in kind
of practical AI are kind of you know
that they're in a sense an embodiment of
the practical version of how and I'm
sort of been been been interested in
that I think it was so amusing to me
that that um you know in the oh you know
I'll tell you one funny thing about
about well many many funny things I
discovered that that movie when I went
back to look at it again
but um you know every so often there's a
there's a screen that flashes up where
it has code like computer code that was
actually IBM was the main organization
that consulted on that movie although
it's out right
that's very how yeah well well that may
have been a coincidence may not be in
consonance I'll tell you one thing I
discover my was writing the blog post
about this is that for IBM named they
were very freaked out by the idea of an
intelligent computer that could take
that could sort of sort of not not
delight the customers so to speak I
think it would try to say them in 2001
without being too much of a spoiler for
the movie but the computer did not
delight
surprise and delight as Steve Jobs would
say right so so the it so IBM was very
freaked out by that vision of computers
so they really wanted to distance
themselves as much as possible so it was
in the movie it was called the Hal 9000
computer and IBM did not have a computer
whose number designations started with a
nine for I think 35 years after that
movie came out so that was a that was
the consequences yeah yeah right but but
no I think that VM in terms of of
science fiction I you know I'm not a big
I'm not a big reader of fiction actually
to my detriment probably and I think
it's it's some you know friction is in
many ways a a way of communicating
things more effectively than probably
just writing down the facts but I'm
probably too impatient to a reader to
deal with that but I think you know this
whole question of when
you get to imagine things in science
fiction versus four how do they come out
and practice you know I was when I was
working on the stuff about tum
communicating with future civilizations
and so on and kind of leaving beacons
from a civilization I I figured out a
bunch of things that have a very science
fiction feel to them and so I thought
this off to some friends of mine who
science fiction writers and one of them
was like I could write an interesting
story about this and started to outline
the story and I was like well that story
just has a lot of fluff around it I just
want to get to the main point so I
thought I'll sit down for an evening and
I will write a science fiction story and
I realized I haven't written a fiction
story since I was a kid
and I write this thing and I send it off
to my friends who are science fiction
writers and they say just just stick to
the stuff you usually do it said some
but it is it's funny I find that you
know in terms of the communication of
fiction you know I've done quite a lot
of historical biography and so on and
for me you know I find it very easy to
write about people and about people I've
known and things like that but when I
have to make up a person where I've
never known yeah somehow that's a
different thing and somehow it I feel
like you know if I say well it's just
this person I'm writing about I probably
could do that but when it's something
that comes from inside me I kind of it
feels too revealing of anything about me
to be able to the person so to speak
first you might sure can influence from
the author or so to speak and it may be
that yeah maybe we'll yeah go ahead but
but no I mean in terms of the future and
so on I think one of the things that um
you know I I've been very interested to
understand what are the kind of what are
the conceptual things that are shaping
the future beyond the kind of and you
know one of the things that's come out
of this visit project for example is you
know the physics project I think is
giving really very good evidence that
our universe is at its core
computational what is it can you take a
step back Stephen King can you explain
for the audience who may not be familiar
what does it mean to be computational
and you know for example the difference
between complexity that we've talked
about irreducible complexity something
like PI where the description of the
thing is the shore
as possible description of the thing but
actually it isn't that though that's
okay
see pi is an example of something where
the description is very short but the
thing you get out is very complicated
one but but I mean just to say something
about sort of what is computation what
do we mean by that essentially all it is
is you have rules for how something
works and you just keep following those
rules so for example one thing I've
studied a lot are things called cellular
automata fancy names simple idea just a
line of black and white cells and
there's just a rule that says if you
have a black cell with a white zone
black cell for example then you get a
black salt the next step or some all the
different configurations it tells you
there's a rule it just tells you what
happens at the next step so it's a
really simple set of rules and you're
just applying those rules over and over
again and ultimately that's what a
practical computer does as well it has
rules that say how its CPU should work
then it's just applying those rules over
and over again mm-hmm so having
something like your beloved and famous
rule 30 what what is the computer is it
the rule that generated this magnificent
complex pattern is it the pattern itself
I mean if I go to you know the cashier
and I say you know how much is it and
she hands me Rule 30 there's nothing I
can do with that it's beautiful to look
at but but perhaps I mean what the
computation is where is it occurring in
the classics project in is it occurring
in the mind is that the universe can you
explain for us where does it occur yeah
right so I mean that's a it's a it's a
little bit of a tricky philosophical
issue because you're saying I have this
rule it says this and this and this
happened okay
that's what theories are that's what any
theory is when when somebody had a you
know when when Newton for example had
his theory for how planets move that was
something where he wrote down a
mathematical equation he says solve this
mathematical equation and you will know
how planets move so there is a sort of a
the mathematical equation itself has
some abstract existence and it generates
numbers or whatever else but
that is merely a description of what the
planets are doing it is not that the
planets are mechanically having you know
a thing that's working out numbers
inside there is Maxwell it's just it's
just that say that's a that's a
description of what's going on so
similarly in the case of something like
rule 30 you know we have a rule that's a
description of what should happen we may
implement that rule on a computer that
may be the way that we happen to see the
results of that rule now the case that's
trickier is for the whole universe
because we now have I think really very
good evidence that the universe operates
in a computational way that there is an
underlying rule and that rule has been
applied trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion I need to be more
practice in counting the trillions but
um that that that rule after it's
applied as many times as we need to
makes us and makes the conversation
we're having and everything and that
that idea so the idea is there's a
there's a fixed rule and it's just
getting applied over and over again now
you say well what's running that rule
well what's running that rule is the
universe that's a description of what
the universe does we could try and have
a computer simulate emulate that rule we
wouldn't you know the universe has been
running a long time and it runs really
fast so we wouldn't get that far doing
it on a you know laptop or whatever but
we might get you know 10 to the minus
200 seconds in the history the very very
very very very you know trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillionth of
a second in the evolution of the
universe on our you know by by emulating
that rule our laptop but the universe
itself what we're saying is the universe
is we can describe what the universe is
doing as its following this rule that we
can think of as being a rule that could
be run on a computer is it because you
know and we should take a very brief
side detour I don't wanna get too too
deep into it there are some who
literally believe that the universe is
being run on a computer sufficiently
advanced AI or you know man if it be AI
might even be artificial and that could
you just comment I've seen a lot on the
internet you know people speculating
that this is somehow connected to this
matrix or this ultimate simulation now
could you just say and you know just
dismiss think it's the firm
it's a philosophically doomed idea that
is because here's what happens so you
know if if I'm right that basically the
universe is is operating according to
some computational rule then at some
level in the end there's underneath
there's just this computational rule
that's running the universe so now we
ask ourselves the question and it comes
back to what we're talking about before
we've got this rule we can hold them in
our hand we can you know we can show it
here's the rule for the universe now we
say was that running inside somebody
else's computer was that a simulation
being run inside somebody else's
computer how will first question is that
the two levels of doom for this for this
idea the first question is what does it
even mean we've got this rule that runs
the universe now you've got to then
argue was this rule created for a
purpose with a meaning by a game
designer a universe designer or is this
rule just a thing and that comes back to
our question of sort of in the case of
human archaeology do we know where the
stonehenge was created for a purpose
even that's difficult when we've got
this little tiny rule and it represents
it generates our whole universe and we
say was this created for a purpose tough
question now it's even worse than that
that's that's the first level of doom
for that that idea the second level
something more a little bit more
abstract that comes out of this physics
project are sort of alluding to earlier
so one of the questions is one of the
things is very strange about this
physics project is the following thing
if we believe there's a rule that runs
the whole universe we can imagine the
day when we actually have that rule and
let's say it's fairly simple okay it's a
very weird feeling because we're saying
you know for the last 500 years we've
basically been taught over and over
again there's nothing special about us
you know from Copernicus origin it's
like the earth is not the center of the
universe
you know there's nothing special about
centers and galaxies right mhm galaxy is
not special the more bright mm-hmm it's
just like there's nothing special about
us okay so now we decode the whole
universe we get the rule for the
universe and oh my gosh it's a very
simple rule that's very special how
could we have got universe number 3216
as opposed to universe number
quintillion quintillion quintillion
whatever how come the rule for our
universe is that simple okay so I've
been really really sort of thinking
about that question for for ages how
could this possibly be B the way it
works but what would it even mean what
is the sort of what is the philosophical
theological implication scientific
implication of here's the rule and it's
simple and what finally realize just
very recently actually is the following
extremely strange fact so if you imagine
the universe that's operating according
to a certain rule and then you imagine
another universe operating College some
other rule but then you imagine the
entities within those universes which
are themselves operating according to
the rule of that universe so be the
observer of the universe has the same
rule as the universe itself well there's
a thing that we're calling rule space
relativity or rule eyo relativity which
is basically the statement so in in
relativity theory one of the things
actually comes older than relativity
Galilean invariance the idea that if
you're in motion you still perceive
things to work the same way as if you're
at rest
that's kind of an equivalence
fundamental equivalence principle in
physics so similarly it turns out that
there seems to be a rule space
relativity which means that independent
of what rule you're using to describe
the universe if that same rule describes
you you perceive the same facts about
the universe so that's a so what that
means is that in a sense when we say the
rules of the universe of this and that
we are picking a certain reference frame
with which we're describing the universe
yes and that just like when we and so
that reference frame just like we say
we're in the with staying still
reference frame
we're in the reference frame going at
100 miles an hour half the speed of
light or something these are all you
know we know from relativity that those
will all sort of perceive the same same
behavior so similarly the the what turns
out to be the case and it's very bizarre
thing these reference frames that have
different description languages and that
have different that that sort of imply
different rules for the universe you can
change your description language change
your rule it'll all work out the same so
to the entity within the universe it'll
works out the same so the only thing
that you end up realizing is that okay
so this is again this is the simulation
argument so this is turns out this game
designer of the universe could be super
lazy because any rule they pick will end
up with the same result mmm well that's
kind of a pretty big downer if your
first question is you've picked a
particular rule why that rule white onto
another well it turns out that the rule
that you end up picking is in a bizarre
way a reflection of our way of
describing the universe that is with our
particular sensors and our particular
ways of doing mathematics and so on we
have created a certain way to describe
the universe and in terms of that ways
to describe the universe we can have we
say the universe operates according to a
certain rule and that's in a sense what
we're trying to do in my physics project
for example is to find the rule that
matches with existing physics find the
rule that with the description language
that we have used for physics is the
thing that explains how the universe
works but but in terms of the simulation
argument this is sort of the the
ultimate doom for that argument is that
in the end it doesn't matter what rule
you pick so if a different rule had been
picked we still in other words that all
those rules are equivalent you can be
the universe could be running all those
rules at the same time it doesn't make
any difference the for the for purposes
of the entities within the system they
can have a variety of different
description languages each of those
description languages corresponds to
some
so it's a little bit complicated I mean
this is I would consider this kind of
the sort of a almost a high point of
kind of the the levels of abstract
understanding of both the science and
the philosophy of what's going on but I
think I think in the end that that makes
it the the designer of the universe
could do basically nothing they just
have to say you know now the part I
don't know and I have to say not without
thinking about it is just because you
have an abstract description what makes
it actualized what what what makes it
actually happen and that we don't know I
have an idea about that which is very
bizarre and abstract but um okay my idea
about that is is more or less than
following they and this may not be right
because this is very new last week's
idea so it's so in mathematics there is
this thing called girdles Theorem and
girdles theorem says just you can have
some set of axioms that try to describe
mathematics and you can end up with
statements mathematical statements which
those axioms can neither prove nor
disprove so actually I'd been long on
the hunt for really simple mathematical
statements where these standard axioms
of mathematics just can't reach those
statements there's no finite proof that
the statement is true or not true that's
girls theorem that says that that can
happen
okay so Goodall had a second
incompleteness theorem that said that
from within a system from within an
axiomatic system the system cannot
establish its own consistency so in
other words you've got this set of
axioms and it's like are these really
right because are they inconsistent
within that system one of the statements
you cannot prove is the consistency of
that system itself so I have this vague
thought that foreign entity embedded in
the universe there may be a similar
undecidability result that basically
says you'll never be able to answer the
question of essentially why the universe
has been actualized and although I
haven't I haven't managed to get that
completely crisp yet right and that's
that's kind of my my best my best
thinking so far about how that how that
might work what one thing that that this
highlights for me so if if you're
entitled and you certainly are as my
guest to to beer into some speculation I
want to run this speculation by you
which is that in my opinion physicists
like myself have sort of a mathematician
Envy in that we don't have the
equivalent of a girdle hypothesis we
don't have a way of describing not what
is physics but what is not physics at
least at close as we typically come and
this is controversial as poppers sort of
dialectic you know the distinction
between a demarcation between what is
falsifiable and what is not falsifiable
as being sort of appropriate fodder for
for consideration by a self-respecting
physics
such as myself or yourself I think the
physicists as I said have envy of math
issues because we that's not accepted by
everybody in fact you know I point out
that popper is he well no you know his
original you know topics for discuss
discussing falsification were astrology
Marxists you know socialist ideals and
so forth and I and I say in my book you
know that all you have to do is look at
you know the horoscope column of your
local newspaper and you'll see that
astrology is alive and well despite
being falsified so it can't be that that
you know that there's something
fundamental about popper so what is the
equivalent or is there an equivalent to
say that yes this is this is physics
what you are doing is physics and then
if not and we'll come back to this if
there's a long explanation but if it's
not true is there something that you in
the physics project can produce that is
falsifiable or or is it something and
this is asked by one of my listeners on
Twitter he asked me to ask you that and
I think it's a legitimate question so
first of all is what do you think about
this this notion that we lack this
equivalent of girdle for physics okay
you have packed many different ideas I'm
sorry but I have thought about for many
years so let me try and unpack a few
infinitely okay so let's start off with
one that's really easy um the analog of
girdles theorem for physics that one is
easy and it's something I first started
talking about in the early 1980s its
computational irreducibility it's this
phenomenon that you can have a system
where the actual behavior of the system
corresponds to a computation that you
can't get ahead of so so one of the
things that was a big surprise that at
first was kind of a footnote actually
and girdles paper actually was a
footnote it got a little bit more
prominent with Touring's 1936 Turing
machine paper and so on on this idea
that okay so one thing you might think
is I want to compute something I want to
compute square roots I want to compute I
want to make a you know do addition
whatever you might have thought that
every different thing you want to
compute you got to go to the computer
store and buy a new computer you'd have
to buy a new new piece of hardware to do
each different computation you want to
do so originally
first arose in a footnote to Google's
paper effectively um that said actually
that's not true you can have a universal
computer which can be a single piece of
hardware which just by changing the
program you feed into it can compute
anything you want and so that idea which
sort of first really getting getting
legs with Turing machines and so on that
idea has sort of well that idea is be
pretty important in our world because
it's what makes software possible it's
basically what makes most of modern
technology possible um that idea for a
long time wasn't widely accepted in
physics people always said but physics
is different physics works using the
equations and things that can't be
described by Turing machines that's been
something I mean I was involved in the
in the 80s and really pushing the idea
that one should take computation
seriously in things like physics and now
with his visits large I think they have
very good evidence for that but so
computational irreducibility is this
phenomenon that you can have a process
go on in nature in physics that is
computationally as sophisticated as
anything it can be it's like you say
well I'm gonna I'm smarter than that
physical system I'm gonna jump ahead I'm
gonna have a smarter computer that's
going to be able to work out what the
physical system is going to do much more
efficiently than the physical system
does it itself but actually we know this
phenomenon of computational
irreducibility says that can't happen
and the sort of infinite time version of
that is the undecidability of girdle
that is if you say what will happen in
this physical system eventually will it
ever do such and such and such and such
then that's not something you can answer
in a finite way and that's that's the
original good or undecidability result
applied to something more physics like
you know mathematics you're building up
he's sort of chains based on you know
the axiom says I can go from here to
here to here that's what you're building
up there in physics you're saying I'm
gonna run this physical law I'm gonna
run this rule for as its behaves what
can happen so that's kind of the analog
there now in terms of the comparison
with your mathematics and physics in a
sense my project is an attempt to turn
physics into mathematics if my project
succeeds physics just became mathematics
if we have the underlying rule
for the universe then everything else in
principle is just computable
mathematically um actually you know I I
was Hilbert had these very famous
problems behind in 1900 problem number
six is his physics axiomatic
so this is um so we can think of our
project I don't think it's the most
interesting view of it but it is it is
this question of can we turn physics
into a branch of mathematics now no this
question of how do you tell whether
something is a valid and worthwhile
thing to be studying
I think Papa's definition is is really
very narrow and I think it's it's it's
good for throwing out a bunch of crazy
stuff yes but it's some I mean if you
think about the great theories of our
time natural selection is natural
selection falsifiable not really is the
second law of thermodynamics that's
another big one which I happen to have
worked on a whole bunch that's another
one with a pretty complicated personal
logical story this thing of mine called
the principle of computational
equivalence which is what leads to
computational irreducibility and so on
again it is it is complicated to say
what kind of a thing it is that is is so
Darwin for example believed that natural
selection was a mathematical law it's
not really true no it's a it's a fact
about it's a it's in a sense it's a fact
about the world it's something to do
with the sort of definition of how
biology works the same of the second law
of thermodynamics same with my principle
of computational equivalence you can you
can have a version of it where you could
mathematically prove it's false but you
might have set up slightly the wrong
thing to be you know you could prove
natural selection is false by setting up
some sufficiently idealized model of how
organisms work um but that wouldn't be
useful because it's not you know it's a
thing that's trying to describe the
world but but I think the the so so
there's a little bit of complexity there
around you know what's important about
these principles like natural selection
like second law of thermodynamics like
my principle of computational
equivalence says they provide ways to
think about things and they're very
powerful ways to think about things and
they provide a way for for us to
essentially turn what we see in the
world into a narrative that's useful to
us now having said that in for example
in this in this physics theory of mine
now one of the really cool things is how
it gov tales with existing essentially
mathematical physics now is it to say
that something is falsifiable to say
that it aligns itself with some physical
law that or some physical principle that
we've that we've understood I don't
think that's quite the falsifiability
story that's a different story that's a
story of of some sort of aesthetic
completeness or something now you can
ask the question you know are there
versions are there things we could
discover that would make this theory of
mine false well there is one if we
discovered that the universe is a hyper
computer that the universe can compute
more than a Turing machine can compute
then we would prove the theory false
unfortunately there's a small glitch
there which is that we humans everything
we do when we represent things kind of
symbolically we have no way to
communicate with that hyper computer so
in a sense even if the universe was a
hyper computer well actually in my
theory there would be a cosmological
circularity cosmological event horizon
that would separate the hyper computer
from the rest of the universe so it
might be there but we would never be
able to communicate with it and even if
we if we said um you know so but but
that's an example of falsifiability I
mean you know it's also the case this
physics theory has a bunch of really
really fun predictions I mean it
predicts some it the predictions are a
little bit hard to say with total
clarity because we don't know some
scales that occur so for example there's
a speed of light that you know we know
about the speed of lights maximum speed
that things can propagate through
physical space in this theory there is
an analog of physical space that we call
branch field space space of branching
structures that represents basically the
space of quantum states and just like
there's a speed of light in physical
space there's also a maximum speed in
branchial space which
response to a maximum speed of quantum
entanglement corresponds to a maximum
speed of quantum measurement my best
estimate right now for the magnitude of
that which is not it's a bit of a flaky
estimate but the best estimate I have is
about 10 to the 5 solar masses per
second so that means that the maximum if
you were a galaxy sized you know if you
were a hyper galactic intelligence the
maximum entanglement speed would be a
big deal for you
just like the speed of light would be a
big deal if you were an intelligence
spread out over even the surface of the
earth the speed of sound is important
for a bad sort of the speed of smell and
diffusion for dogs right interesting but
I mean just to finish that thought I
mean so this this maximal entanglement
speed if we were to see black hole
mergers between 10 to the 5 solar mass
black holes we should see effects from
max if the scale is correct we should
see effects from that ah so this would
be in principle observer ball with LIGO
or depending on the distance right if we
were lucky enough I think we'd see it
anywhere in the universe if - if Chloe
implanted black holes
you know merged it sounds a lot of
galaxies that's right and you know not
enough galaxies not enough time that's
right but but there's another thing
which we I mean they're just a boatload
of predictions so that they're a bunch
of things so another one has to do with
photon correlations photons orbiting a
black hole there is I think a prediction
about the way that correlations should
should occur for photons orbiting a
black hole that probably you could also
get from you might also be able to get
it from quantum field theory and
relativity possibly but it's now
actually maybe that isn't even true it's
it may be specific to this theory
because it requires a merger of
relativity and quantum mechanics which
is what happens in this theory and what
hasn't really happened anywhere else
presumably thermodynamics would enter in
as well with with Hawking radiation at
those same boundaries well actually
thermodynamics is is more of an
underpinning I mean I I you know
thermodynamics so the second law of
thermodynamics for people you know it's
basically this law 1870s it was
originated
that says things tend to get more random
in the world so if you have a bunch of
gas molecules you very carefully arrange
them in some corner of your room and
then you just let things go the gas
molecules will end up randomly arranged
around the world and it's been very
confusing to people
how can it be because those gas
molecules when they collide you could
always play the movie in Reverse and
whatever the you know whatever the
configuration of gas molecules was in
the end the gas molecules it's as valid
a sequence of collisions between gas
molecules to say they go back and they
end up being in the corner of the room
as to play the movie forwards mm-hmm
people have been quite confused about
that I think I kind of figured that out
in the 1990s actually and it's kind of
nobody seemed to care at the time um and
it's been interesting with this physics
project now the number of questions
about thermodynamics is quite large so
I'm really happy because it was the
thing that I was interesting when I was
a kid I finally figured it out in the
1990s and the story is this basically
when when those gas molecules are
diffusing out they make something that
seems random tasks the reason we can't
invert it is essentially the same reason
we can't break encryption what's
happening is there's been this
irreducible computational process that
has essentially encrypted the initial
conditions the initial conditions are
still there but they've been encrypted
and the the thing is that we as
observers making our measurements doing
you know figuring out how many gas
molecules there here and there those
measurements are not computationally
sophisticated enough to be able to do
the decryption easy so that's the reason
that we that it appears that things have
become more random even though if we
look to the microscopic scale and we
decrypted what had happened we will be
able to say AHA that came from something
very simple we can't actually do that
and that same phenomenon happens so in
this physics theory
um when you do in in general relativity
in the theory of gravity you're
interested in essentially the way that
observers in the universe can kind of
piece together different parts of the
universe
what's acceleration what's a
gravitational field and so on turns out
the exact a so here's a little little
thing for you this is particularly the
work of young fellow who's been working
with me Jonathan gorod
um that the thing called the cosmic
sensitive hypothesis which you're
probably familiar with at least is
directly follows from essentially
computational irreducibility arguments
and that follows in the same way that
the second law of thermodynamics follows
that because you can't have an observer
who sort of Catholic sculpts their
reference frame that's why you end up
having things like the cosmic censuses
so and I mean I'm there's a rather
technical thing that some of these
issues about Hawking radiation that and
the actually I think our resolution of
the black hole information paradox it
makes some implicit use of computational
irreducibility but it's not quite front
and center I mean what happens one of
the mysteries about black holes is you
can start off with this pure quantum
state it's all you know it's all
perfectly quantum mechanical then the
black hole forms and then you starting
to get this Hawking radiation which is
this very thermal non you know breaking
laws of quantum mechanics type thing but
then in the end the black hole
evaporates and you think well I'm back
to my original perfect quantum state and
how did that work well in our Theory we
actually have a way to understand how
that works it turns out that there's an
event horizon which you know anything
that goes past the event horizon never
gets to come back out again but there's
another event horizon the event horizon
the usual event horizon is associated
with essentially an escape velocity more
than the speed of light so if there's
another horizon that is not in physical
space but in branchial space which we
call the entanglement horizon which is a
horizon where this 25 solar mass per
second thing comes in and you can't
escape from the entanglement horizon and
so things get trapped between the event
horizon the causal event horizon and the
entanglement horizon and that's where we
think actually just this afternoon we
were doing because we're doing this
crazy thing of life streaming a bunch of
our internet science discussions and we
were just doing one this afternoon where
I was realizing that something I thought
I understood about black holes I was
wrong about but where we actually can
where we were getting towards being able
to have an absolute
explicit picture of how this phenomenon
works of quantum degrees of freedom
being trapped and inside the
entanglement is purgatory between the
entanglement to the classical or the
event horizon and now this new branching
horizon other sort of a purgatory regime
between us two I say okay and that is
your your conjecturing that is sort of
the associative nexus of where we're
hawking radiation phenomena I would take
place where do article anti particle
interesting so so do when you I mean
this is sort of reminding me of this
classic you know discussion which I
don't want to have about you know
whether or not mathematics is discovered
or invented but it does seem like and in
particular because you gave some hints
about this in in your book adventures of
a computational a computational Explorer
and you started talking about you know
where you we were going and sort of the
the cover depicts this landscape of
discoveries and and but it's but it's
not only discoveries it's also
inventions obviously in the case for
Wolfram it's literally technology that's
being invented so actual devices and and
and and machines that can do actual work
in the computational landscape I want to
ask you know when do you start to get
this ink when you start to get the
inkling that you're onto a discovery or
invention something that's new I wanted
to just you know harken back to to to to
your book Adventures of a computational
explorer and you talk about the the
feeling the alien feeling that you have
when you are you know coming upon
something that is new or something that
had been known before like in this case
you talk about general relativity and
you say special and general relativity
are things that physicists normally
assume are built into the theories right
from the beginning almost as axioms or
at least in the case of string theory as
consistency conditions the idea that
they could emerge from something more
fundamental is pretty alien and I think
I don't know if you're paying attention
to how much reaction that the physics
project is getting online and the blog
is
fear and reddit and all sorts of places
Twitter etc but I feel that there is
sort of this this back reaction that's
occurring literally where people are
finding it so alien that they almost are
shutting down I mean I've heard you know
friends of mine who are some of the most
eminent physicists in the world
basically saying things like well I
believe it when it's in a top-ranked
journal and and we'll talk about that
and how things are going with the actual
logistics of publication etc but but
this is this is sort of new and it's
it's its novelty is enhanced all the
more by the way that you sort of have
chosen to release it and and how you've
documented the kind of exploration log
as you're going about you're doing this
in real time you're doing this open
source and you're doing it in a way that
is discoverable and Pratt in principle
by anybody and I wonder you know what is
that is that is that disappointing to
you the kind of yeah I want say
hostility but I will say you know people
are very skeptical and it's not like as
I point out it's not like you know I I'm
a living example of you know peer review
and not being a panacea for for some of
the things that that I've managed to get
by editors and referees but but it's
still sort of the best tool that people
think of scientist is manifesting - can
you comment on yeah look I mean the fact
is that that physics fields of science
go through periods of rapid growth and
periods of kind of slow grinding sort of
hard slog for a century mm-hmm and what
you see I've seen this probably in a
dozen fields in my time where there'll
be typically a methodological advance
and then for maybe five or ten years
there's a very rapid growth the field
may not exist before that time or maybe
like machine learning where it had been
stagnant for 50 years and then suddenly
comes alive and lots of exciting things
happen or back when I was working in
particle physics in the late 1970s was
another sort of period of rapid growth
and those are the the dynamics of new
fields or fields of rapid growth are
very different from the dynamics of
fields were in there they're in the
cruise phase so to speak and so you know
I think when
the physics that we have today the two
great theories of physics today quantum
field theory and general activity are
both 100 years old general relativity
was 1915 quantum field theory 1920s and
you know I'm sure if I'd gone back and
talked to you know Albert Einstein or
Verner Heisenberg or one of these kinds
of people about the things we're doing
today they'd say oh ok that's
interesting I'm not surprised you know I
mean I know Einstein had even written
things that said I'm pretty sure
space-time will end up being discrete
but we don't have the tools to
understand how to work on this yet
mm-hmm you know he wouldn't be surprised
but you go seven academic generations
later you go a hundred years later
physics is not about you know big
changes now physics is about you know
it's a field that has achieved great
things I mean they're different areas of
physics but when it comes to the sort of
fundamental physics thing it's really
about let's make an incremental change
and you know fields have this character
it's kind of you know I've sort of been
an entrepreneur both intellectually and
and commercially um you know it's a
funny thing because when fields are
young they're very sort of it's all very
entrepreneurial and people you know
they're prepared to question the
foundations and so on when they get
bigger in order for the thing not to
just completely self-destruct it has to
be institutionalized in some way they
have to be there has to be structured
they have to be you know one of the
things I've I've sometimes said is by
the time there's a prize for something
it's too late for anything really
original to be done by the time somebody
has decided this thing is a field for
which there's a prize that field you
know is already mature and a little bit
unfair but but but but there's something
to that I mean I think that the the you
know by the time there's a professional
society by the time there's lots of
journals by the time there's a
department in a university what's
happened is there's a normal there's a
thing that is the normal way of making
progress and the system isn't set up to
to see something different actually I I
almost have a good story to tell from
just last night I was
was my friend Paul Ginsburg who who
created this thing called archive which
is big preprint server that gets some
I've never because I I worked on physics
and wrote academic papers before Paul
invented archive I've never used archive
right so I decided I'm gonna upload this
four hundred and fifty page paper yeah
well I linked up there in physics to
archive and you know we uploaded it and
it kind of got stuck and that's it's
like I'm sending mail to Paul why is
this stuck and he's like well because
big and it's complicated and so on and
so on and so on and I'm like I really
want to be able to tell the story that
anytime there's a there's a paper that
says that mentions fundamental theory of
physics you're blocking it from archive
that's not true so if I can't tell that
story but but in a sense that story
wouldn't be implausible because when has
anybody made any serious claim that they
have a you know a big jump forward and
finding a fundamental theory of physics
I actually get emails almost on a daily
basis from from people as shall we say
around the world who have you know could
trying to convince me that there is a
fundamental theory that they've invented
it that Einstein was wrong and you know
I always say it's surprising to me that
they don't off start off saying you know
Boltzmann was wrong or some other you
know lesser-known celebrity than
Einstein but in fact I mean you're not
saying he's wrong you're saying he's
right but you're making not necessarily
a prediction in some sense it seems like
retro addictions are I mean and I
scented that as well Einstein retro
addicted the perihelion advance of
mercury as we know and that was early
evidence for the veracity of his theory
no I mean so there are there are
predictions we didn't even come to those
but they're a bunch of predictions it's
difficult because they don't have a
scale Einstein was lucky that his theory
basically didn't need a scale so he
didn't have to say I mean he didn't need
one scale which was the cosmological
constant about that he was plenty
confused but um his his theory because
of the nature of the theory it doesn't
have a scale the same is true for my
theory when it comes to phenomena that
happened near black holes and things
like that
but those are sort of special cases a
little bit far away from what we're
dealing with right now there may be some
predictions of the theory in quantum
computing that again don't require
knowing certain scales and so on
and strangely there are also well
there's a whole different story about
applying the sort of mathematical raw
material of the theory to areas like
distributed computing and so on which
have a different different kind of
character to them but just just going
back to sort of I mean yeah I've got
some I get a huge number of these I've
got a theory of physics to type tight
emails um and you know I think it's kind
of look it's like many people write
poetry and so on and it's you know the
poetry is interesting and meaningful to
them it may or may not have a profound
you know global meaning it's mm-hmm
right it doesn't mean I think the thing
that is that is surprising to me and
that is my main comment about these
things is you know we have if we were
going from just our everyday experience
to a fundamental theory of physics it's
hopeless
I mean there's a couple of thousand
years of development particularly the
last 300 years of pretty intense
development of kind of synthesizing
things we know about the world and
turning them into things like Einstein's
equations or things like the final and
path integral and so on there was a deep
condensations of things we know about
the world so in a sense if you're going
to try and discover a fundamental theory
of physics you are making us
unbelievably hard for yourself if you're
not leveraging what was discovered in
the 20th century basically in physics
and the thing you know I have the the
strange feature that I learnt all that
stuff when I was a kid um and you know
that's a that's kind of a weird piece of
kind of life trajectory I was a big
physics enthusiast I started learning
about physics when I was 10 or 11 years
old and I wrote my first paper which I
published in a in a peer-reviewed
journal no less when I was 15 and the
and you know so I had learnt sort of the
standard Canon of 20th century physics
quite well I then went on to kind of
work on things which in many ways I
think are more fundamental than physics
I think sort of the computational
universe is in a sense the universe of
all possible universes the physical
universe is is just one of those so I
view it as almost a step down
you're working on sort of the physical
universe now although it's really
interesting and I'm really fun but I
think that the the question of sort of
what time so you know there's a there's
a good question of how do you do make
non incremental progress what's involved
in making non incremental progress in
science so when I used to be in the
physics business way back when you know
I wrote lots of papers I think my peak
productivity period I was about 18 19
years old I was writing a paper every
two weeks um and it was easy because it
was a field that was in such rapid
growth that term and also I had a secret
weapon which was I was using computers
to to calculate things which for some
bizarre reason other people were not
doing but in any case you know I could
say when it came to it like peer review
and so on I could just predict if the
paper is incremental progress and
something that's already well understood
it'll sail right through if the paper
actually has a new idea in it forget it
it's it's some that's too alien over of
a structure that's been built to deal
with a particular status quo now you
know for example in I mean I've been in
a sense a lot of what I do
building computational language you know
I've been I've been doing something that
in some ways is kind of insidious and
people haven't yet noticed and I'm
wondering how many decades it's gonna be
before even though I'm telling you here
it's some how many decades it's gonna be
before people notice I mean I might
comment on the do people notice you know
the physics theory that I'm now talking
about I spent a hundred pages talking
about the precursors to this in this big
book of my new kind of science yes and
you know we sold maybe four hundred
thousand copies of that book and
millions of people have looked at it
online I gave some talk at Ted that you
know where people have launched it and I
talked about this theory physics in fact
somebody reminded me recently but in
that in that TED talk which was just
about exactly ten years ago I said you
know I wonder whether by the you know
let's see whether by the end of the
decade we can actually you know hold in
our hand the theory physics okay so
let's say a million two million people
watch that it defined kind of the the
the story that has turned into the
physics project that I've now now been
doing
and yet basically nobody followed up the
million you know multiple millions of
people and so I think it again relates
to this thing I was talking about
earlier about sort of the context of
understanding things you have to have
you know if it's sufficiently alien it
just doesn't have it doesn't resonate it
doesn't doesn't connect with things
people know what to do with right I
think in in you know one of the things I
was saying that that term you know a lot
of what I do is design in computational
language to sort of bridge this thing
between humans thinking about things and
computers doing things and you know I've
tried to sort of make you know in sense
what I'm doing is something like when
people invented mathematical notation
four hundred years ago or so now they
were inventing a way of describing
mathematical thoughts that was easily
transferable in that case from person to
person what I'm trying to do is
inventing a way of transferring
transferring computational thoughts both
person to person and person to computer
and once it's person to computer the
computer can take it away and do very
powerful things with it yeah but in a
sense that notation is a way of defining
how people think about things and the
fact that you know I spent 37 years of
my life sort of trying to build this
notation for how to think about things
what I can already see is for example in
this physics project some of the ways
I've thought about things there when I
work like this afternoon I was working
on quantum spin and the origins of
quantum spin and you know I can
perfectly well tell the way that I named
the functions the way that I defined the
functions in this computational language
they affect how I'm thinking about
things so getting back to our language
mm-hmm but so in a sense you ask you
know what I mean I I have been in the
business of basically trying to define
how people think about things but not in
they let me persuade you right type mode
more in the let me give you a tool that
I've tried to make us as efficient as
possible at extending what you might
have thought about anyway but you know
give you a track for thinking about
things yeah it's kind of people haven't
noticed how how important them power
that is because you know people who know
like wolf in language well you know they
can form thoughts in that language much
more quickly than they could express
them you know talking in English or
whatever else and they're really
thinking in that language and that
that's the thing that's a very you know
it's a very powerful thing to be able to
do but it's also something where it's
kind of a different you know you're
asking I mean it's it's a different way
of kind of reaching people than then
they let me persuade you that my theory
is right to tell you right yeah I've
often you know thought to myself that
the best way to read one of your more
technical books mm-hmm such as you know
new kind of science is to actually read
your popularization for example you know
as a companion so in Chapter two of
adventures you talk about you you have
the following statement you're talking
about searching through this vast
landscape to find the core phenomena the
root of the core phenomena from a
perhaps deterministic underlying model
then you say what is the rule for our
universe and then you say I don't know
yet searching for it isn't easy one
tries a sequence of different
possibilities then one runs each one
then the question what is has one found
our universe now obviously you wrote
that just less than a year ago and and
then you said you know in a little bit
later you say I certainly think it's
interesting almost and I believe that
the answer now is yes right I mean I
think you would say yes you have found
our universe within the physics project
I found a course of things which
includes a universe I would say that we
still have I mean the what's left to be
done
okay so here's one of the things that is
that is both surprising and interesting
so this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that I keep on talking
about even though you know the rule it's
hard to know what its consequences are
that bites us big time in studying
fundamental physics because let's say we
have the rule we start running it okay
we've got the first kind of minus 200
seconds of the evolution of the universe
okay what about the next 14 billion
years right you know we have to go and
and you know we don't have a way to get
there now the big surprise in this
project of the last few months has been
that a
facts about universe are not
computationally irreducible a lot of
facts about the universe are deducible
by essentially mathematical type
techniques knowing that just knowing the
costs of rules that are used not the
specific rule and that's a thing that
Tim you know in retrospect and it's
typical for me at least
in retrospect it's obvious but it wasn't
obvious for the last thirty years of my
life
so what's obvious is the very fact that
we humans are able to make sense of the
world means that it's not computational
irreducibility all the way up so to
speak because if it was computational
irreducibility all the way up and the
thing that we would see in the universe
we'd say I don't know why that's
happening because I have to be able to
trace it your micro step down at the
lowest level but what we know is that
there's actually great regularity in the
universe that we can make use of and
that in a sense tells us there must be
some layer of computational reducibility
and basically what we found is 20th
century physics basically is the layer
of computational reducibility that sits
on top of what we now think of as this
kind of irreducible substrate and no so
you asked about predictions I mean there
there are lots of interesting ones I
mean as I say it's slightly damaged by
the fact that except when you're dealing
with black holes and things there are
some scales that we have to we don't
know what values they have we may figure
that out even fairly quickly and there
are ways I can imagine figuring that out
but you know you talk about Tim you're
talking about sort of the dynamics of
the sociology of science it's an
interesting thing because you know I've
been involved in you know starting some
fields and I mean I it's sort of
fascinating that you know like the whole
area of sort of studying complexity for
its own sake you know back in the 80s I
was kind of I suppose I was a main
standard bearer for a large part of that
and you know I wrote the sort of the
prospectus is that the manifestos for
why that was a field that was worth
studying okay so I reckon that I made
some mistakes in defining that field
which it's interesting the extent to
which they've kind of bitten what
happened I mean the number one mistake
that I made was not to define an analog
of pure mathematics in that area so what
happens is you can have this idea simple
rules do complicated things now the
question is do you study the simple
rules for their own sake or do you only
study them in the service of
applications of those rules and what
happened in mathematics which might not
have happened it's a historical accident
in some ways that it happened is that
this field of pure mathematics developed
that is studying mathematics for its own
sake and people might say why do you do
this I mean it's like it's it's just
people will say oh because it might be
relevant some people say oh because it
might be relevant to technology I don't
think that's a totally convincing
argument or might be relevant to science
you know the other the real reason is
because mathematics managed to attach
itself to education and it meant that
there was sort of a market for
mathematically knowledgeable people that
ultimately was driven by education I
mean you know at the same time in
history logic you know it used to be the
case back in the Middle Ages and so on
mathematics and logic were neck-and-neck
you know they were both part of what
people would learn well notice that you
know everybody's obsessing about math
education who's obsessing about logic I
think that's right and that's the
fundamental predicate for everything
that mathematics is based on right well
yeah so what one can think that but I
think that the you know what's
interesting sociologically is
mathematics managed to attach itself to
sort of education logic didn't so much
and that what that led among other
things to this internal market basically
for pure mathematics and in the area of
complexity and so on the internal market
of just studying simple programs for
their own sake didn't develop as much as
it could've I mean there's been there's
been you know a hundred thousand papers
only written on those kinds of things
not like there hasn't been work done but
but it isn't as big a thing as it should
be perhaps even will be and could be and
I actually think the physics project
will help in kind of emphasizing the
importance of studying simple programs
and what they do as an abstract
essentially mathematical like thing but
the
methodology is not like mathematics I
mean you know it's also perhaps worth
commenting on on it's been interesting
to me see and I because I was I was sort
of I think it's fair to say I was a I
was a you know sort of top of the line
physics operative back when I was twenty
years old or something
and so I know a lot of people who were
in physics at that time who are probably
twenty years older than me or more um
and fortunately many of them are alive
anymore but but um those who are
significantly older um and it's been
interesting with the physics project you
know I I've been sending email to all my
old friends and physics many of whom
I've kept up with over the years sort of
saying hey there's this new thing and
it's it's it's amusing I mean the
responses I get back
it's a fascinating kind of sort of
shell-shocked II type response it's like
that's not supposed to happen right yes
right hey that's it's not it's and to me
I mean I didn't think it was going to
happen either you know I thought what
was going I didn't think you would you
didn't think you discover it or you
didn't think they would react that way
because I thought I didn't have other I
say I thought that what would happen is
that it was going to be a you know I had
an idea that I thought was a good
direction and I thought that the
progress will be glacially slow I did
not think that we'd find out I mean the
the the huge surprise is that we were
able to figure out so much quite quickly
and and I just you know it's like we
broke through this dam and it became
quite easy I mean it's kind of like it's
not supposed to be that way I've never
seen it in terms of sort of a most of
the work that I've done in science and
technology is what we'll might call more
synthetic so this because in your like
you're building a computational language
you could do anything you want
yeah it's evolutionary make it useful in
in my work and new kind of science for
example and studying the computational
universe the computational universe is
so vast you can go and explore some
different directions in it you know you
try and figure out general principles
and things but it's it's not but as
physics has this feature that there's
this one universe sitting in front of us
and you know how does it work and I
really didn't think we would find it
nearly as easy
sort of understand a lot of things about
it and I think the things we've
understood so so for example you talk
about people proving that Einstein was
wrong or Einstein was right and so on
there is one way in which we sort of
deviate from Einstein at you not so much
for Einstein more from minkovski who was
sort of a teacher and disciple of
Einstein's I guess and you know what one
of the things that came out of what
Einstein did with relativity was this
idea of space-time the idea that you
know time and space are sort of the same
kind of thing and that really got
cemented by the work that makovski did
on the mathematics of space-time very
elegant work which has been very
important in the last century of physics
but from that idea came the notion that
is absolutely burnt into essentially all
physics that's done which is time is the
same kind of thing as space you know and
you might say well gosh you know I can
move in space but I can't move in time
my same way you know to us as a sort of
intuitive humans it's like how can you
say space and time the same well you
come up with all these thought
experiments of trains moving at the
speed of light and so on and you kind of
convince yourself that space and time
are kind of like the same thing and you
can kind of twist yourself to say yeah
they really are and mathematically works
out beautifully to say that but one of
the features of this theory is time and
space are not intrinsically the same
thing time is kind of the inexorable
operation of computation and space is a
feature of this hyper graph that
represents the sort of extent of the
universe and time is discretized they're
both with discretized yes they're all
discrete and setups but but the thing
that so you might say gosh you're doomed
you know you'll never get relativity but
it isn't true you get relativity very
easily as a consequence of kind of
large-scale behavior of a system like
that and so no that was a place where
we're basically was it's actually
historically interesting I think I'm
pretty sure it was a wrong turn in the
history of physics I'm pretty sure that
if I look back at the early days of
relativity and quantum mechanics to me
that's the only obvious wrong turn the
other the other sort of pseudo wrong
turn is quantum mechanics where people
said you know my friend dick Feynman
always used to say no
but he understands quantum mechanics Hey
okay and I think he was right I mean I
knew how to calculate all kinds of
things in quantum mechanics you know you
can crank up the mathematical formalism
you can calculate all kinds of things
you can calculate just you know what is
it eight nine decimal places or
something even more amazing but it's
like why does this work what's really
going on we didn't know and now we
actually have an idea how it how it
works and it's really it's really quite
wonderful and it's it's the thing that
to me is just like absolutely
spectacular is what Einstein's equations
which describe gravity and space-time
turn out the analog of those in this
kind of branch field space of quantum
states is basically fineman's paths
undergo G and that to me is just like
you know these are two sort of defining
ideas of of 20th century physics and
they basically seem to be the same idea
but just applied in different in
different settings and that to me is is
really I mean that's a for me that's a
real Wow and it's it's really it's
really something I mean I get very
excited seeing that because it's just so
beautiful that that's something like
that could could be the case and I sense
it you know that's things like that by
the time you have enough things like
that happening yeah you can worry about
whether the telescopes will observe the
first prediction that you get but I
don't really care about you right I
think it's the faith that you need to
have based on you know accuracy that's
been demonstrated right and the
efficiency you know I always say that
you know echoing Dirac Dirac you say
it's more important that your equations
be beautiful than that they be right I
think you're sort of the opposite camp
but but the beauty is emerging because
it's sort of it's sort of satisfied like
nobody likes the idea that that that
that space and time are the same thing
for the very reason you say it's it's
like I'm convinced nobody likes the idea
that the earth is actually spherical or
nearly spherical it just doesn't comport
with our cognitive biases and yet it's
true right and there's something even
more beautiful about it being true but
it's yet it's violently opposed at first
at least
I wonder what the consequence yeah go
ahead one thing to say about theories
and falsifiability inside.i it's worth
knowing a few stories to keep in your
kind of you know your falsifiability
you know quiver or something yeah okay
Liam
you know Newton in the his Principia
1687 yeah he's got this big chapter
about the moon and he's trying to
compute the motion of the moon turns out
it's pretty hard to compute the motion
of the moon he had the right theory but
it's pretty hard to compute and he goes
through his whole long chapter lost
sentence of the chapter is but the apse
of the moon is twice as great so in
other words he did his whole calculation
he got an answer that was wrong by a
factor of four to two right now if he
then say oh forget it all my field of
gravity must be wrong he didn't because
there was so much other stuff that and
it took another hundred years for people
to figure out you know how that factor
of two was you know really worked out
and it was a difficult thing
so that was a you know that's a sort of
you know the flip side of that is kind
of what happened with Copernicus where
you know there were Potomac epicycles
and you could compute all kinds of
things about planets and didn't really
matter you know Copernicus had a
slightly different way of formulating
things you know I find it amusing we you
know in in often language we have to
compute astronomical kinds of things and
like we did a big thing for the recent
total eclipse that was visible from the
US you know computing to the second
using using work from JPL and other
places you know when would the eclipse
arrive how do you actually compute it
well the answer is you use ten thousand
epicycles so in other words you know
even though Copernicus won Ptolemy was
wrong in the end the computation is done
with epicycles I mean and but so you
know Copernicus was a case where the
theory was in a sense at some level more
correct but the
calculations were actually he didn't
even get as good results as Ptolemy's
got right and and it wasn't then you
know I have to tell a story when I was
in particle physics back in the 70s um
one of the first so one of the things I
was involved in doing was making
predictions from QCD the theory of
quarks and gluons about what one would
observe in experiments
okay so had this one paper I wrote I was
calculated the rate of charm particle
production charm quark production mm-hmm
and you know we got an answer well it
turns out there was an experiment that
had been done that said the true answer
is less than five times lower than the
answer that we got okay so it's like
what do you do okay so the Poppa
falsifiability thing says okay throw
away your paper right well I was
sufficiently sure that QCD and my
calculation were correct that it didn't
do that
you know sent out the paper now
admittedly half the paper was here's why
this answer might be wrong okay but in
the end well I wouldn't be telling this
story if it wasn't for the fact that it
ends with and the experiment was wrong
right it was an experiment and actually
that experiment taught me an important
thing which is whenever I subsequently
did theory based on experiment I would
insist on actually visiting the
experiment and going to look at the
experiment and ask a bunch of questions
and it was really shocking to me how
often I remember one experiment big
particle accelerator experiment so I
could observe this anomalous production
of particles in some direction and it's
like I'm looking at this thing and I'm
you know I'm doing sort of
back-of-the-envelope relativity
calculations to figure out in the rest
frame of this thing whether the
particles go and so on it's like you
have claimed that you observe in excess
of particles in a direction where there
are no detectors and just you know the
the how can this be you know it's
complicated story and it's you know it's
a big Monte Carlo simulation calculation
to sort of back predict from what they'd
seen was total nonsense
yeah but victim but the thing is you
know experiments are hard yeah and you
know it's
it's particularly well that like that
first experience I had it was kind of an
experiment that observed nothing and
that's always very suspicious because
it's like they were looking for particle
tracks and emulsions and it's like how
long is the particle track how good is
your detector how do you know if you
didn't see anything
you know you observe nothing you sure
that's right well it wasn't right in
that case yeah it's you know so I've
kind of learnt that sort of theoretical
triangulation is sometimes at least as
important if not more so than you know
the the the the sort of the eye dotting
and T crossing experiment even even the
case of general activity and Einstein I
still don't quite understand what
Eddington did in 1919 is you know the
story is Einstein predicted that when
when light is goes around the Sun that
it will be bent twice as much as
previous theories has predicted that
there's essentially a gravitational
magnetism as well as gravitational
electrical force analogues gravitational
lensing yes mhm yeah right but there's a
factor of two there would be even
Newtonian gravity yeah naval prediction
but but it's a factor of two different
in relativity that's right so a giant
Stein got wrong initially in his
original calculation which which could
have been borne out by an eclipse that
occurred in 1914 but for the fact that
there was World War one going on during
the path of totality it didn't take
places serendipitously the it was good
for Einstein because as he's later said
you know when asked what wouldn't happen
what would have happened if if he had
been proven wrong he said I would have
felt sorry for the good Lord because my
theory is correct but he would have been
starkly proven wrong falsified even had
the events of World War two not taking
place that's right and in fact you know
some doubt that that Eddington was
really capable of achieving the
precision on glass plates don't forget
kept in quarantine for six months
between you know where the stars are in
the background of the solar field you
know between these two observations yeah
you're absolutely right it was and not
really confirmed with the accuracy that
nowadays we physicists would accept
until radar astronomy in the 60s and
seven and now of course we know it you
know two exquisite accuracy it's one of
the most highly test
the teachers of relativity yeah go ahead
no I mean it's always interesting to me
that the intersection for example in
this story of Eddington and Einstein and
so on I mean the whole you know the
whole geopolitics of global one ending
and you know German Theory English you
know verification all this kind of thing
there was a you know there was a
complicated in that case even
geopolitical backstory beyond just the
sociology of a fields backstory that's
right it was something even even bigger
than that going on that yeah I have a
friend
we interviewed on the podcast Matt
Stanley who wrote a book called
Einsteins war it was interviewed on this
podcast as well so we'll link to that in
the show notes yes there's geopolitics
there's international intrigue and kind
of chauvinism national chauvinism and
actually the fact that Eddington being a
Quaker as Matt Stanley is actually was
one of the you know decisive ask
attributes of why he was so pivotal
pivotal in the story right I mean I
think they took by by that but on those
levels of issue the the response you
know is it's it's fascinating to watch
the response of new ideas you know in
long-established fields yeah I would say
my rating of this physics theory is it's
going really well that's that is it it's
been I've seen other cases where you
introduce something into a well
developed field and there's much more
immune response yeah would say that the
you know what I'm seeing here is both in
terms of established physicists it's
kind of kind of fun because they're just
not used to something like this know it
so they say you know it's gonna take me
a while to digest this and it's only
getting signs of digestion okay right
you know what does this mean in such and
such a place in what you've written so
that's a to me that's a great sign it
means you're really reading stuff and so
on I think that the you know we're also
seeing lots of them things like physics
graduate students and so on who are like
I want to get involved we're going to be
doing a summer school this year to help
people kind of get get up to speed on on
this we've actually done a summer school
for the last 17 years about about
science and technology in general but
we're kind of adding a physics track
this year specifically about the
fundamental here
oh great I will definitely put
information in the show notes about that
that's a wonderful opportunity yeah just
to remind you of a famous Arthur show up
in our quote that all truth passes
through three distinct phases first it
is ridiculed secondly it is violently
opposed and third is a it is accepted as
being self-evident so may it be accepted
so because I know that you're after the
truth and the truth indeed I want to you
know sort of start to come in towards
the towards the airfield and and
conclude and respect your time I want I
want to you know again I just want to
add one thing about Sharon said because
I think it's kind of interesting to
people so you know when I wrote this big
book big book I have a big book see this
yeah a big book
it's a good it's I usually keep it on
the floor by my desk actually because
it's it's too big to go anywhere else
but um you know the main point of that
big book is that there's sort of a
different way to think about the world
that isn't in terms of kind of the
mathematical equations that people like
Newton and so on introduced back in
1600s as a way to think about the world
but it's this thinking about the world
in terms of rules and programs and
computation and so on
okay so put this out there and what was
interesting as I now realize there are a
lot of fields which accepted this quite
quickly actually the one field that had
the most kind of pitch for curry as I
call it was some fundamental physics
physics and physicists but the thing
that's been really interesting lost you
know it's eighteen years since that book
came out and if you look at the history
of modeling and science okay for back if
you said to somebody twenty-five years
ago said how would you make a model of I
don't know road traffic flow how do you
make a model of people searching the
internet how would you make a model of
how you know leaves grow on plants or
something they would say well I would
think about an equation I would write
down this equation I would define all
these things mathematically and I would
try and solve the equation etc etcetera
etcetera okay and that was the tradition
for 300 years well now if you
of people how you gonna do it you look
at the new models people are making of
things they are essentially all
computational models they're essentially
all we have a rule we have a program we
run it this is what it does we can
analyze it sometimes in terms of
mathematics and I think it's pretty
frigging spectacular actually but after
300 years of kind of what had been sort
of you know back in when Newton was
first introducing this stuff there was a
lot of fussing about it you know how
could you be discussing things purely
mathematically
there's no way to reason your way
through what happens it's just
mathematics philosophers were very upset
about it etcetera etcetera etc but after
300 years that's the orthodoxy yeah and
and then last 15 years or so well it's
all changed but that's been a
fascinating revolution because it's been
quite silent it's just happened yeah and
that was I mean I give myself a little
bit of credit because if you'd read the
preface to a new kind of science I
basically said that was what was going
to happen yeah and that is that what you
know and nowadays you ask people how do
you make a model of I don't know
something about you know epidemics or
something well there are the
old-fashioned differential equation
models there are the new kind of agent
based network e-type models the the new
stuff it's all kind of programme based
models and people say well of course you
do that right yes yeah that's the
transition you know you talked about
these phases that's the thing that as a
you know for the individual involved in
the paradigm shift so to speak it's just
really a weird thing because I just you
know it's only 18 years ago that people
were saying it can't possibly be that
way they're going to work it's all
stupid and then the sentiment literature
and a hundred percent of it is of the
new models of being produced practically
a hundred percent of working that way in
one area which was not affected in this
way of transition to kind of
computational modeling was fundamental
physics yeah and that's a thing that
basically we just changed last week yeah
and I think you know as I said the very
early you are you know by nature of the
voluminous output that you produce and
by nature of the fact that you work on
such high stakes aspects of mathematics
of computation
of physics it's natural that you're
gonna be drawn a controversy will come
to you because of the stakes that are
you know in play here and I do again I
want to encourage people to you know
read these books along with the
popularisation z-- because I think it's
impossible at least in your case to
dissociate people cannot not take you
seriously because you've done you know
objectively you know foundational work
in all these different fields I do want
to you know just because you mentioned
this this slow evolution and then you
mentioned you know kind of these
paradigm shifts and I I like to think of
it almost like a Stephen Jay Gould used
to say you know punctuated equilibria
like will go through these phases and
then something new will come along and
what irritates me is that there'll be
people who who will you know decry the
state of physics and say it's been
stagnant for the last forty years and
yet when some something new and
groundbreaking potentially comes along
they'll say well you know it does you
know I don't understand it it must not
be right and I'm not gonna invest my
time in it but again you cannot ignore
it it you know time will tell certainly
but but as you say you wrote the kind of
science 18 years ago I camera I can't
believe that because it seems like only
it seems like yes I my coffee is getting
old
yeah exactly and I again I want to
encourage people to read you know for
example to look at Adventures of a
computational a computational Explorer
and and see the things that that what
Stephens talking about here and how they
have borne fruit and you in fact talk
about not punctuated evolution but you
talk about these paradigm shifts you say
it's sort of a Copernican moment well
get to know just how special or not our
universe is something I wonder is just
how to think about whatever the answer
turns out to be it somehow reminds me of
situations from earlier in the history
of science Newton figured out about the
motion of planets but could not imagine
anything but a supernatural being first
setting them in motion
Darwin figured out biological evolution
but couldn't imagine how the first
living cell came to be and I want to
always point out that people say things
about Darwin as you know is this
ultimately prescient person who had the
most important theory of all of science
but again he had yet his blunders too he
said things like it is mere rubbish
at present of thinking of the origin of
life one might as well think of the
origin of matter and of course we we we
know now a great deal about Big Bang
nucleosynthesis my late colleague
martyred Burbidge and the and the theory
and with her with her colleagues on how
stars produce nucleus and nucleotides
and and how we don't really appreciate
things while we're in the midst of them
and I wonder you know if if if what
keeps you going is sort of this this
knowledge of history as you've done a
lot of episodes of the history of
physics not just through the lens of of
your particular vantage point but I
think from an objectively interesting
standpoint of what these major
breakthroughs were and how of course the
culmination that's in xscape about this
physics project might just might fit in
to that in the future history of this
fellows room you know I think you
mentioned Darwin and I I'm I'm you know
I'm moyson I like history right so I'm
always one of the very fascinating
mistakes that Darwin made it's probably
I consider one is most his most
interesting mistake is the last line of
Origin of Species
so he says icon I don't have it in front
of me so I won't get it precisely right
but he says basically just as the earth
is rotating around the Sun according to
the fixed law of gravity so new species
ever more complex are being produced
before me in thought he thought it's a
very very interesting idea it turns out
to be wrong but it's a really
interesting idea that there is an extra
ability to the production of complex
species as a result of some some force
that he tried to work out didn't succeed
one of his maids actually was who became
a mathematician tried to help him do
this to figure out is this sort of a
mathematical theory of the way in which
sort of what we now understand others
things like complexity and so on can
arise and he thought that like the law
of gravity tells us about the you know
the earth going around the Sun but there
might be a similar thing that will come
out from natural selection you know I
think that the this this whole you know
you were you
talking about some people and there you
know what happens when you're in the
middle of paradigm shifts and so on it's
you know I've been through a few of
these I mean first point is you know why
do I do this stuff well first because I
find it fun second a thing that has
really been an interesting dynamic for
me in recent years particularly is and
it's really happening great with the
physics project is that I find it I
really like putting things out there
that other people have a good time
thinking about in other words it's some
you know I don't really it's not that
it's not the satisfaction of oh I got it
right it's more the satisfaction of I
put this thing out there and people are
having fun with it I mean it's kind of
more like a I suppose it makes me closer
to you know somebody in the
entertainment business or something then
than the you know I'm trying to I'm
trying to nail it for the sake of having
you know I mean I I'm you know I find it
both internally for myself you know I
have my own sort of standards and and
definitions of success and I don't
really care what other peoples are and
on the other hand the thing that I
really do get something out of is is
being able to give people you know being
able to sort of provide fulfillment for
people and I like to think that I do
that in the kind of computational tools
that I build and I've been really
pleased to see in this physics project
that um that that's a dynamic that seems
to have been picking up and I think that
the I mean the thing to understand about
you know about history the two things
that I've learned from from studying
history
um which maybe answer all this what one
of them is people say oh you know 1905
Einstein introduces relativity
you know everybody understood you know
relativity is easy to understand it's a
five page paper which has basically no
references um and you know it's amazing
it got through peer review I don't know
how that happened I need to go find his
friend was Pierre I think his friend was
an editor okay I'm blanking on his name
but yes yeah yeah right but I think the
the
that that's usually the way it works if
you actually want to get it through peer
review is the the for a new idea that is
um but I think that the the you know the
thing that you know the real story is
you know 1905 1910 nineteen you know it
took many many many years before people
routinely accepted the theory of
relativity as more than just this weird
pseudo philosophical kind of pseudo
mathematical type thing and you know
it's it's always the first thing is
these things that you read in history
books that say you know such-and-such
was discovered boom everything changed
it happens more with technology actually
than it does with intellectual things
but that's the first thing the second
thing is when you read in someplace so
and so on this day figured out this
grand idea okay that never happens
either what happens is that you end up
having to build up this intellectual
context and it takes years decades
sometimes once you've built up that
context then maybe there is some
triggering event that happens very
quickly but without that there's always
a there's always a story behind you know
all these things where it's like
so-and-so noticed this thing and that
was the you know that was how they
discovered whatever it is it's never
true it's always so and so was thinking
about this and working towards this and
had an idea that was going to happen oh
and then they saw this particular thing
and then BOOM a lot of stuff happened
and that's you know that's the that's
the experience from the inside so to
speak is that it's glacially slow
yeah if in terms of the response I mean
the response in the world is always it's
just charming to me because it's always
it always works this way you know at the
beginning I think you were you were
quoting this sort of principle of how
this works but I think that's absolutely
right I mean in the beginning it's like
oh my gosh can't possibly be this way
but cetera et cetera et cetera and then
then eventually it's like but it was
totally obvious yeah that was Moses that
way could it be any different right and
you know I think that that's
I mean for the individual involved in
initiating that it's a it's an
interesting thing to watch you have to
be um and I think for me I you know I've
actually always had a certain degree of
detachment from which is not necessarily
always you know that's that's a
challenging thing for ideas to what
extent you just put the idea out there
in the world and to what extent do you
package it and to what extent do you
push it yeah and so my point of view is
I put it out i package it as best I can
I don't spend a lot of effort pushing it
yeah because and packaging it means you
know for me that means do I write you
know do I try and make the thing
accessible do I try and for me that's
you know that's super helpful for me too
because like I've been for this physics
project like last Friday I did a kind of
briefing for kids about the physics
project where I was trying to see you
know could I get the physics project to
a middle school type level and you know
I think I did okay but I had a bunch of
ideas actually while I was doing that
while I was talking about it because I
realized this is an easier way to
explain this thing and by golly it helps
me understand it right that's you know
that's a but by the time it it's it's
more kind of like the the go convinced
people make it and the person says you
know but I've been doing physics this
way all my life right it's like well I
you know I don't know that's right
whatever I think now yeah it would be a
new kind of marketing instead of a new
kind of science you need to really push
it I want to talk I want to conclude
with a couple of just cuz you know it's
it's my prerogative as the host and if
you'll indulge me I want to ask you a
couple things first of all you were on
guy Kawasaki's podcast though late last
year and and he said something in the in
the notes sort of to the audience that
you may not have heard but basically
it's the fact that you're the smartest
person that he ever met and I want to
point out that you know one of the other
people named Stephen that he knew was
Steve Jobs of course and he he related a
story you know where he had you know sat
in or just had talked to Steve Jobs a
writer
the time that that I believe Mathematica
was sort of getting its name and and
that Steve played a role in the creation
of the name although you came up with
the name but nevertheless he convinced
you of doing that I want to talk about
that the creative mind and but also
something that you share in common with
him in my opinion which is your your
your you know your ability to motivate
teams and and I saw that firsthand you
know we've known each other for five or
six years now but I've seen it with your
team and the interactions that I've had
with you that you're exquisitely
organized you're very disciplined but
you have this camaraderie that you build
up within the team that as you describe
in adventures as sort of you know like a
movie set
and when they wrap up that you're you're
compiling these projects and I wonder
when you were working with Steve and and
and sort of were there lessons that you
got from him obviously it made its way
into the into the next machines and that
eventually led to Tim berners-lee
you know creating arguably the world
wide web on the machine that had
mathematic aronia right yeah so history
is the footnote to history so how do you
you know as leader cuz you're not only
you're also CEO of a company and founder
of it how do you go about this this
process we're gonna have links to this
wonderful blog post that you wrote about
a year ago about kind of your life hacks
and so forth but you know what the
typical thing for a mathematician you
say how do you know if a mathematician
is outgoing they look at your shoes when
they talk to you instead of their own
you don't have that you're not you're
not shy and you will have the ability to
to motivate people into the lead and I
wonder where does that come from does
that does that come from being a student
of corporations or how do you figure out
how to be a leader and I think that in a
real thing with leadership as far as I'm
concerned is to you know define a vision
and be able to have something which
you're excited about communicate that
excitement to a team and it's also about
caring about people and knowing
something about people I mean I've been
you know I think I've been you know over
the last 33 years that I've been
building up my company you know I've
been fortunate enough to accumulate a
lot of super talented people from around
the world and
you know it's I find people interesting
people you know figuring out how does
this type of talent fit in to what we
need to do at the company you know when
we build a new project it's like it's
like a puzzle like we've got all these
talents we've got all these projects we
want to do how do you fit them together
I mean I think it's it's some you know I
think as far as I'm concerned it's it's
a lot about you know defining something
you know I think my responsibility as a
manager is to make sure that people have
something interesting to do and to make
sure it's something that they care about
that they're feel fulfilled when they've
achieved it you know those are things
that I think are important that's my
responsibility so to speak you know
maybe their responsibilities to actually
do the work to help make that happen but
my responsibility is you know keep it
interesting keep it something that's
really meaningful to the world I hope
and to the people who are working on it
and I think you know the the this point
about I mean I happen to be interested
in people I think Steve Jobs was had a
he has very different I mean his in my
style of managing people I think is
probably different I mean his his um you
know one feature of anybody who does
hard projects hard big projects have
never been done before is they take a
lot of just pure human pushing effort to
make happen and you know what does that
translate into I think Steve's way of
doing it may be slightly different from
my way of doing it but I think we both
probably shared the fact that we could
get really pretty pushy in trying to get
projects to happen I think the way that
the way that the reason that happens I
finally understood you know we've done
many software releases we've done many
you know big projects and it's like why
is it that at the end you know well I I
said for a long time I said there's
never been we you know have a team I
worked with for a long time doing big
software releases it's like we've never
had a calm release a fully calmness why
is that but and then having had that
theory we finally had one that was
basically really very calm about a year
ago so I you know to every theory
there's an exception but but really what
happens is teams get they work on their
part but when you're integrating the
whole thing
together to build the final thing
they're always a pieces that weren't in
anybody's silo so to speak and so
somehow you have to push all these
pieces together and sort of bridge those
gaps and that's one of the things that I
think requires the most kind of sort of
human pushiness but I would say that for
me I mean I happen to find people
interesting I happen to you know not I
think if I didn't I would have gone
crazy CEO in a company for more than
half my life because you know it's you
always see weird things happen people
there's always some weird pathological
thing that happens and it's like I've
never seen that one before but but also
it's you know I think it's it's I like
to believe that I can work with a very
wide range of different kinds of
personalities and that it's possible to
to figure out for these different
personality to different skill sets you
know how can they fit into some overall
vision that we have and that's I find
that interesting
rather than frustrating um you know I
think other people might find that
frustrating so I mean I think I I am for
whatever reason I you know I kind of got
to two interests in life one is in kind
of drilling things down to sort of this
reduction this level of doing sort of
intellectual sort of clean clean
thinking type stuff and the other is
people who are kind of almost the exact
opposite of that yeah you know Steve
Jobs one thing that I always liked about
Steve very clean thinking guy very much
a you know what's the point what's the
point what's the you know what's the
essential point not what's all the
complicated you know fluff around it but
what's what's the core essential point
and you know I think that that in a
sense a lot of you know what I try to do
in science and in technology is
similarly sort of what's the point type
them type thing and it's some but but
not so much with people I think it's
different different different and
different interests interesting yeah I
want to just you know close up with a
couple more comments questions about
legacy and this is again from adventures
of a computational explorer
you say lessons of the past in the
chapter called our section called
lessons from the past a few years ago I
was visiting a museum and looking at
little wooden models of life in ancient
Egypt that had been buried with some
kings several millennia ago how sad I
thought they imagined that this would
help them in the afterlife but it didn't
work instead it just ended up in a
museum but then it struck me
no it did work this is their afterlife
and they successfully transmitted some
essence of their life to a world far
beyond their own and it reminded me a
little bit of of a quote by Sam Harris
who is you probably know a very popular
podcaster author neuroscientist he has a
chapter in his book called waking up
which is subtitled a guide to
spirituality without religion and he
says in a thought experiment from the
philosopher Derek Parfit
I think that's how you pronounce the
name asks us to imagine a teleportation
device that can be map ursin from Earth
to Mars rather than travel for many
months on a spaceship you only need
enter a small chamber close to home and
push a button all the information in
your brain and body will be sent to a
similar station on Mars will you be
reassembled imagine that several your
friends have already traveled to Mars
this way and they seem to be none the
worse for it they described the
experience as being one of instantaneous
relocation you push the green button and
you find yourself standing on Mars where
your most recent memory is of pushing a
green button on earth and wondering if
anything would happen so you decide to
do it and it goes on a little bit he
says this has the benefit of leaving
nothing to chance the fact that before
you get transported and teleported they
obliterate your original body this has
the benefit of leaving nothing to chance
if something goes wrong in the
replication process no harm has been
done however it raises the following
concern what if your double clone of you
is beginning his day on Mars with all
your memories goals and Prejudice is
intact you'll be standing in the
teleportation chamber of Earth just
staring at the green button
imagine a voice coming over the intercom
to congratulate you for safely arriving
at your destination in a few minutes
you're told your earth body will be
smashed to atoms how would this be any
different than simply being killed and I
thought for a second you know this kind
of brings up this notion of of legacy
right because if
you can be teleported into a different
place in space how is that different in
this in this thought experiment from how
you get transmitted or teleported in
time and if as you say you know we can
separate space and time perhaps you know
in what ways could this could this take
place first of all let me ask you you
know in terms of legacy is that how do
you define it
I'm defining it as teleporting my values
into time throughout history and into
the future not so much in space it
doesn't interest me as much there's a
famous quote you know I'd rather have
one reader of my book a hundred years
from now than 100 readers of my book a
year from now and I think I'm curious
what is your what what do you see as
your enduring legacy perhaps or what
would you like it to be oh I don't know
I I think that I'm you know one of the
features of the kind of science and
philosophy that I think about is that I
kind of slowly realize more about kind
of the human condition and what sort of
what the arc of what the in a sense you
could say well gosh if you figure out
the theory of the universe then that's a
thing that will sort of last for the
lifetime of the universe but that's not
true what you figured out is for humans
Karen now this is how to understand how
the universe works it's all centered
back on humans again and I think that
one of the things I've realized is that
the the you know the the permanence of
anything one does it's very much
embedded within the context of some
particular moment in history so to speak
so it's not the case I mean you know one
can have you know it's kind of it's kind
of fun to imagine so to speak the you
know what will fit people think 500
years from now but you know one of the
thought experiments that I like to do is
to ask you know how does human purpose
evolved over the last millennium let's
say you know I walk on a treadmill for
you know a certain amount of time how do
I explain that to somebody from a
thousand AD it's like totally nuts you
know how will the people of the future
what will their value system be how will
it mesh with our value system today in
maybe there's something I've done that I
think makes perfect sense that people
will think is utterly shocking in 50
years maybe there's something that you
know is I mean these are these are
difficult things to know I mean I think
that um you know I think you know the
whole question of sort of human
permanence or impermanence I mean that's
a whole different issue where you know I
suspect you know one of these oh it must
be impossible stories is the whole human
immortality story and it's not
impossible it's just one of those things
that has to be figured out I mean it's
complicated it's like if I've got a
server a computer server and it's been
running for you know a month and then it
crashes the crash is because of some
weird problem that happened at cetera et
cetera that's kind of analogous to what
happens with us humans um but you know
we don't even understand it for computer
servers let alone understanding it for
the more complicated case of our sort of
molecular computing thing that's us so I
think you know one of the things that
term is is interesting to think about in
your sort of I would say it's a ship of
theseus yeah Derek profits thing is a
kind of a a version of the ship of
theseus transported in those few
millennia forward so to speak that
wasn't so an old philosophical kind of
question of when you replace pieces of a
ship you know board by board when is it
the same ship you know at what point is
it does it stay to being the same ship
or not if it's been completely replaced
right right I mean so so it's some but I
think you know it's an interesting
thought experiment
imagine immortality
either biological immortality or digital
immortality you know what does it then
mean what do you then what are your
values when you if you can achieve
digital immortality or biological
immortality I think digital immortality
is probably the more extreme case
because it has you know for example
biological immortality still has issues
like there's only one of you um whereas
digital immortality that isn't the case
at all um and you know so what do you
then it's sort of an interesting
question let's imagine I I think my my
version of this has been the box of a
trillion souls what if the future of
humanity is in our box of a diddle you
know I think the very notion of a soul
is actually kind of a fascinating
projection from the distant past into
this idea of computation it's there's
there's something about brains that
isn't physical what is it now we know
it's basically computational in the past
that was described as you know the soul
so it's really it's this this box of a
trillion digital souls and you know
let's imagine that's the future of
humanity and that's where you know some
of us at least in the future end up and
then the question is what is the value
system at that point what is the you
know you say I want to have a legacy and
you say well okay I'm I'm plopping my
legacy I you know I'm one of these
people who records you know every
keystroke I type and all this kind of
thing whereas cameras to conferences
right yeah that type of thing so you
know and III certainly suspect that
there's enough data kept about me that a
it isn't a big a I effort to reconstruct
me from the data that's kept about me
and the question then is okay so what
yeah and and you know then then we'll
have to ask is so there's the
reconstructed me or there's even the
digitally uploaded me that's in this box
of a trillion souls what do I then care
about mmm what what thing do I I mean
it's it's some so I I I don't claim that
I've resolved this question either for
myself or for anybody else but I I think
one of things I find interesting about
these sort of philosophical and
conceptual questions is this when
you know in its kind of like for example
in this physics project actually
imagining that we might have a serious
chance of finding the rule for the
universe really gets one running in
terms of thinking of that the philosophy
of it when it's still often the distance
it's one thing but I think you know I
haven't really internalized the
philosophy of digital uploading and so
on and I think you know at some point I
you know I I it's a it's a worthwhile
thing to think about and I you know so
the answer I'm giving you a very long
answer to a short question about you
know how do I feel about legacies of
things the answer is I don't really know
how I feel yeah because I think that you
know we are at the first time in history
when there's one bizarre thing to think
about okay weren't the first time in
history where a lot of what's going on
in the world is being recorded yeah so
we kind of know what happened now if you
look at a lot of human history people
say what's the real point of life the
universe and everything a lot of what
people look at is you know works from
antiquity that tried to define that and
that were you know what will written at
a time when they were the first things
on the block trying to define those
things and they had good things to say
and those things are probably still true
because human nature doesn't change much
um but you know people were looking to
you know to the Past to know what's
important and so on they were looking to
these and so one of the questions is
when we look to the future you know the
box of a trillion souls when we're when
we're free of all kinds of limited
resources and all these kinds of things
one of the most bizarre things that I
can imagine is people will say oh those
guys at the beginning of the 21st
century we know exactly what they did
and why they thought about things they
must you know that is true humanity
right there that's what we have to go
figure out why they did what they did
because now we don't have any of these
constraints you know where there is no
sort of true humanity anymore because we
don't have the constraints that they had
at the beginning of the 21st century
their ego and you know let's go look at
all those podcast episodes and trying to
understand you know let's try micro
reconstruct you know why did they do
what
did because that is the true meaning you
know that's that's the thing that I mean
in this question about sort of the
translation of meaning and there's no
abstract version of meaning meaning
comes from the sort of historical thread
and we we are in the part of the
historical thread where we're recording
what we do but we're not yet to the
point where there is where there are no
constraints so it's sort of a we may
have more responsibility than we think
so to speak yeah outcome about what you
know the future of human history is and
and I think that there will be pieces of
that that are big pieces that are you
know I mean I'll be you know like this
idea of computational irreducibility you
know that I've had that idea is going to
be very important for the future of
human history you may not know that yet
but you know it's I mean just like ideas
like force and momentum that came out of
you know the science of three hundred
years ago have been important in ways of
thinking about things
you know I was I was amused last summer
I happened to be giving some testimony
for the US Senate and it's the first
time the word can computational
irreducibility made it into the
Congressional Record yeah that was one
something about in that particular case
it was a type of law that just can't
possibly make sense mmm yes hunter you
know this is going to happen more and
more of understanding what can we
understand what can we not understand
only have the AIS what do we you know
what is the Constitution we sat down for
the a is about what we want them to do
and not do
how does it all work you know this that
idea like like many of these things I
mean I can tell you now and you can go
you know check it out in however many
years computational irreducibility will
be it's already a reasonably known thing
but it will be a very well-known thing
in time yeah in time it will seem
completely obvious interesting yeah and
then how you know revolutions in physics
which you wouldn't necessarily think
would have theological or philosophical
implications you know I mean just
thinking about from Newtonian and kind
of Aristotelian even you know prime
movers to Newtonian you know angels
keeping the universe from contracting
itself - obviously the quantum
revolution and and all those
implications that come from a you know a
very analytic branch of human
intellectual discourse and and yet make
their way into these you know sort of
very weighty implications and I wanted
to finish up the discussion that we're
having and schedule a future one because
I want to come back after the book comes
out and I want to get to that in a
minute but I want to finish up a three
you know kind of short question answer
questions oh goes always the list I know
one of them will be well one of them
will be very short because it's just
standard but this one may or may not be
I want to go to the opposite direction
we talked about your legacy which is
legacy of us as as human beings as
fathers as you know people teachers and
educators etc one of the opposite
direction if you so in my book I have
this wonderful quote from Soren
Kierkegaard who you know really sums up
the astronomers kind of dilemma which is
that his quote is that life can only be
understood backwards but it must be
lived forwards and I want to ask you in
a you know in a brief way what what
aspect of life was you know perplexing
mysterious that was hard for you to
understand admittedly you were very
precocious you know twenty-year-old with
a PhD from Caltech but as a 20 year old
what was mystifying about life that now
makes more sense to you perhaps now with
the with the benefit of time has brought
you some wisdom about it I'm you know I
think I think um you know look I've
slowly learned more and more about more
and more kinds of things I mean I I you
know it's kind of the the it I mean one
of the things that I saw has been a
fortunate thing in my life is just kept
learning more stuff and I have a decent
memory so you know gradually after
you've learnt enough fields learning and
you one is more efficient and you make
all these cross connections I think the
you know I was when I was 20 years old I
was doing physics and that was all I was
doing and that was all I knew about it
didn't know about companies I didn't
know about I knew about computers as
well but um you know I didn't know about
all these different kinds of things and
so you know that for me is the the fact
that um I think if you'd asked me then
all these other things interesting I
would have said yeah no I think physics
is the most interesting thing but turns
out lots of stuff is interesting I think
the I mean my my wife would for example
say about me that you know one feature
that I have is I'm one of these people
who has to figure out everything for
themselves you know nothing and and
she's always giving me a hard time you
know that you know 25 years ago she told
me something rather and then I suddenly
say okay now I'm gonna do this if like
everybody knows you should do that 25
more years to figure it out it's some I
think that the you know probably
probably the the wisdom of everybody
else maybe was not I I I've slowly
learned probably that you know my
default of is the wisdom of everybody
else correct versus do I have to figure
it out from first principles maybe has
changed slightly I'm sorry I need to go
in just a moment here so okay so I just
want to finish up with a question I
asked all my guests that do you think
that creativity imagination our Center
is named after arthur c clarke center
for human imagination
it can creativity of the kind that you
exemplify cannot be taught can it be can
it be something passed on from a mentor
to a protege or is it something that
really is inborn innate intrinsic don't
entirely know and you know i've i'm not
through lack of data so to speak i mean
i think that look i think a lot of
people have intrinsic creativity i think
it is often squashed out of them i for
example the educational system or by the
the expectations they think the world
places on them I mean I I you know one
of my kind of hobbies has been sort of
trying to teach about computational
thinking and other things to like middle
school kids and younger and so on and
it's it's really fun and it's really
interesting to me um and I think the
uh you know the thing that is
interesting that at the middle school
ish age it's it's really fun for me like
explaining things to kids of that age
because they they just they don't have
any fear of asking questions about all
kinds of things later on they're much
more uptight much more like you know Oh
what are people gonna think of ask this
question is it a good you know whatever
so I I think my working hypothesis would
be that sort of everybody has a quite
good degree of creativity it's a
question of whether they have the
forcefulness perhaps confidence or the
things around them develop enough of
that that they can bash through and
apply it I mean you know things I've
done like you know this physics project
of mine this is you know it took even me
and I've been involved in you know big
projects I've done lots of things where
people said couldn't possibly work and I
do it anyway and it works out just great
and so on you know I've had a lifetime
building up confidence to do projects
that are difficult and sort of you know
out of the mainstream and even for me
this project took decades to have happen
and almost didn't happen
and so I think it's a it's a you know my
feeling is there's you know the effort
to get your creativity out II that's a
big challenge and can the world help
people with that they probably can can
you can you add on creativity on top of
somebody who's sort of had it squashed
out of them I don't know but you know I
think it's intrinsically there and it's
really the challenge is to just to just
reveal you can express it and get the
confidence to be able to do it excellent
okay I want to thank you for your
generosity of your time and your ideas
and your and your thoughts I'll put in a
little bit of a plug zone you can find
Steven on Twitter at Steven underscore
Wolfram you can find Wolfram Alpha you
can find as many books we'll link to
them all Wolfram calm and I just want to
thank you so much for this wonderful
conversation and chance to pick your
brain well yeah that was so much fun
thank you so much Steven have a
wonderful evening
Thanks
see you like
[Music]
the only thing to do is show up about
the future is it for the answer
[Music]